Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Good morning.
I sound less dead inside because I actually woke up an hour before the stream was about to start.
Lately, I've been sleeping a lot earlier than I used to because I've been very unhealthy.
I don't know.
I think, honestly, I need to start being more healthy.
But, like, it's been a lot of stuff going on.
But... Because I couldn't... I couldn't stay up yesterday.
Um... I'm so proud... What?
Proud of me being unhealthy?
Like... Um... But, yes, uh...
I've been heading to bed a lot earlier than I'm used to, which is, like, before... either before midnight or, like, around 1 to 2, which is something I'm not used to.
I'm, you know, I'm sitting here, like, 1 to 2 is both healthier.
Like...
But you understand, sometimes I would get to bed a lot, lot later than 1 a.m.
Um...
But, um, I've been getting, like, I've been feeling, like, really, really tired lately.
Which I think is just me being, like, unhealthy in general.
Which means I gotta, you know, I gotta change my habits.
I guess that's not good.
Um...
I'll do...
Every time I say that, I'll be like, starting tomorrow, I shall change.
I shall be a better, healthier person.
Starting tomorrow!
But then, like, tomorrow never happens.
And I'd be like, you know, starting next week, I will start being more healthy.
Starting next week!
Ha ha ha ha!
Eventually, eventually, you know, I'll get there.
I'll start lying to myself until, like, it becomes the truth.
Ha ha ha!
That's how it goes, right, guys?
Also, uh, Bluth, welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
I know today is gonna be, like, an incredible...
Today's stream will definitely be a lot more calmer, a lot more chiller than other streams.
Because a lot of stuff is happening today.
A lot of stuff has been happening the last couple of weeks.
Ha ha ha!
But, and I was thinking, like, oh...
I was debating whether or not, um...
I should move today's stream to a different day.
Or, like, you know, postpone Dynasty Warriors yet again.
Ha ha ha ha!
Due to, you know, obviously today is a big day.
Um, it's a big day.
And, uh, I figured, you know, a lot of stuff has been happening, you know.
I know there's some dragoons that, uh, just really want specifically to watch me.
And I decided to keep on streaming today because I was like, you know what?
You know, maybe there's some dragoons out there that's been feeling really down.
And need some comfort, need some company.
And I decided, um, today to...
To stream, to just, you know, I didn't postpone today's stream.
I was like, you know, I'll stream for the dragoons who might need some company today, who might need, you know, who might just really was looking forward to today's stream with me.
So I decided to keep on streaming today and, you know, keep those dragoons who need a new pick-me-up today to keep streaming.
And what a great pick-me-up it is that we're playing our favorite game, Dynasty Warriors, where you get to see, like, we together, we together, get to romanticize.
And some more Chinese generals.
What a great pick-me-up.
Our favorite dating sim simulator.
Yes, we.
This is a group effort.
We are romanticizing.
We are romanticizing Chinese generals together.
What happens to me happens to you, too.
This is a group collaboration with the dragoons.
Winter World, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, give me a sec.
Let me message, do a work message real quick.
Also, okay, I'll say what.
It's basically, I'm just messaging the respawn staff to be like, what can I say and not say about the early access for the new season?
Like, I don't know.
They're like, oh, yeah, you can tweet it out.
I was like, okay, what can I?
I just need to be sure.
What can I not say?
Is there anything I'm not supposed to say?
Because it would be awkward.
And then they're like, oh, you're not supposed to say blah.
And I was like, what for it?
He said it on stream.
It's all right.
They don't watch my streams.
They don't watch the pre-talk part before I play.
Luke, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've just been catching up on Mario Monvide.
I've heard about the cost of dad surgery.
I know it's not much, but here's some money to offset the cost.
And best wishes to dad for his speedy recovery.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, yeah.
I basically get like morning updates about dad.
Let me read today's text message from the babysitter.
I'm not going to be moving for a bit.
All right.
Here you go.
Good.
He's a bit more mobile when going to pee.
And otherwise, just chilling out.
Taking his meds, fine.
Just napping a bunch.
I'm trying to rehab a bit, but he doesn't like it.
Oh, and then he has like his little...
They sent me a picture of his baby gel.
He's like in.
Let me see.
I need to save this.
Okay.
I'll save...
I'm going to try to save the photo and let you guys see.
But he's in a little baby gel right now.
Uh, because obviously we don't want him to fucking...
Oh my God.
I actually saved the photo one, two, three, four, five, six...
I accidentally saved the photo seven fucking times.
Oops.
Because I was like, why won't it save?
And I kept pressing the button and I see the fucking photo saved seven times on my phone.
Um, all right.
Let me show you guys a picture.
Sorry, I'm not moving because I have to read the text.
All right.
This is his baby gel that he's currently trapped in.
Let me transform it to...
Fit to screen.
Okay, here we go.
All right.
So this is what the baby gel looks like.
He's currently in here.
He's in, he's in baby gel at the moment.
Um, Quantum, thank you for the five gift of chips.
Thank you.
Um, contained by his crimes of jumping too much.
All right.
I have him in this soft crate we have.
He will usually just nap most of the day.
He's going to be in trouble once he's feeling better.
He's already trying to go upstairs.
And I can see him wanting to jump up on things.
I think he just isn't because he's still hurt.
You're going to need a lot of those dog stares.
So far, I'm just blocking it all off so he can't.
I was like, why are you trying to jump?
Dad, why?
I was like, what do you mean?
He's looking, he's like, eyeing the stuff out.
He's like, yeah, I'm going to jump on you next.
He was born to jump.
It's literally not in his genes.
He is genetically bred to not jump.
He's trying to defy his biology.
No, I am not paying another $10,000 just so my dog can jump.
I am doing a hard time for his crimes.
And thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He has dreams, Doki.
He might have been born a wiener.
But he, his spirit is that of a golden retriever.
Let him, let him have his destiny.
Pouring the jump, forced to be a wiener dog.
But yes, he is unfortunately in prison right now.
He, he is, he is caged up for his crimes so that he will not jump.
Um, but yeah, that is the current, uh, current dad update.
Uh, what else do I have to talk about?
Uh, okay, uh, bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu And today,
I'll give you guys something exclusive for those who are here.
The preview for next membership wallpaper.
Sorry for the non-member goons.
Sorry.
But this is going to be the outfit themed for...
I know, guys, I know I missed April.
But it's also because the artist needed more time for the wallpaper.
For those... Okay, for the member goons.
Um, I know I missed April.
But don't worry, you guys are getting two wallpapers.
Because also, the artist needed more time.
So, we're going to get two wallpapers in May.
Maybe three, I think.
Because I think I missed another one.
So, here is the outfit preview for...
This is usually the outfit preview.
So, like, you know, non-member goons will be able to see this as well.
When, um...
So, yeah.
This is...
It's going to be a coffee shop themed.
And, uh...
This is the outfit that's going to be for the coffee shop.
So, yay!
A little preview, guys.
Woo!
Yeah!
All right.
Preview done.
Uh...
Yay!
Minimum wage token!
Oh, man!
I sure do love minimum wage token!
That's so fucked up.
Let's see.
I'm going to...
I'm going to hear where Sirenia set the sound correctly.
Would she beat me up when I get copied?
Don't piss me off.
As long as you don't piss me off, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Heroic, thank you for the super chat.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doing hard time for his crimes.
Champion, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad will jump for beefy.
What?
Nice dad.
Okay.
All right.
Let me...
Let me boot up the game, guys.
Whoa!
Dynasty...
Oh, guys.
I need...
What the fuck?
It's still getting updates?
What is it updating?
Additional features.
And...
Oh, and they just added photo mode.
Oh my god, we get photobode?
Wait, this is the best of... I was like, oh, wait.
And then it clicked in my head.
What that meant?
I was like, oh, they just added photobode.
Wait, photobode?
Alright, let's see.
Open the menu on the world map or the battle and press the touchpad button.
Okay.
I just need to get to the and press the touchpad button.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
And the real dating sim.
Okay.
This is it.
This is what I... Finally, an update for me.
All I'm saying is that if I didn't prolong my Dynasty Warriors playthrough, I would have never got photobode.
So it was all planned.
I get photobode.
Alright, let's test it out.
Finally found myself a job.
It was all calculated.
I don't even remember.
Okay, wait.
I was on a horse?
How did I... Wait, I can be on the horse this entire... Oh, wait.
No, I can't.
I didn't realize... Wait, I can get off, though?
Oh my god.
Photomode can be entered with... And then...
Join the... In photomode, you can control and create... Oh my god.
Photomode... All right.
That's good.
All right.
Now, I'm just... I needed to learn that in advance, guys.
Finally!
What I've been demanding for this entire time.
Hello, Jonfei.
Can't get... I mean... Hold on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
What do you want?
Jonfei.
Oh my god.
Is this another... Already?
I just started the game.
How...
Am I ready on a dinner date?
How are we on a dinner date already with Jonfei?
Now we're great officers.
Getting audiences with royalty.
I don't know what it is about my brothers.
But the Emperor and Tao Tao seem to have taken a liking to them.
Thinking back on it now.
A lot has changed since our early days.
Look at us now, Jonfei.
We're hot.
We're rich.
The only thing that hasn't changed is me.
And...
And look at these guns.
No, you're perfect.
Being a drunk alcoholic is like what every woman wants in ancient China.
Or man.
You know.
You don't...
We forgot to be left side dokey.
Okay, guys.
Give me a sec.
It's time to be left side dokey.
Wherever she is.
Oh my god.
Where is left side dokey?
Where...
Where is she?
Where did she go?
Okay.
That's not left side.
Where is left side dokey?
Anyway.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm trying to find...
Nope.
That's center dokey.
That's too...
A little to the right dokey.
Oh, there we go.
Left side dokey.
Okay.
Here we go.
So, these were my options.
You don't need to change.
And I'm...
That seems like the best option.
Well, isn't that nice to hear?
If you really think so...
That's right.
My brothers always seem to have their heads on straight.
They don't get mad.
No matter what.
And I lose my temper at the first sign of trouble.
Don't worry.
Some women like that.
That's the one thing that's never changed.
Speaking of changes...
You're quite different than you were when I first met.
That girl little Tali?
But your eyes is more and less in the same place.
I always feel at ease with you.
How do...
How do I...
Any different?
Whoa.
Oh, Fade of Black.
Oh, the classic.
Oh, wait.
It's night time.
Nothing has changed since Dong Zhuo's rule.
Wait.
Just what it's out.
It's out thinking.
Treating his majesty like this.
Well...
Wait.
This isn't my dating sim date.
He is the one who's in control of the court.
To him, the emperor is a mere puppet.
What is this?
Plot in my dating sim?
I didn't ask for a lord.
His majesty would never fear a charlatan like him.
Well...
I am so glad our dear emperor is pained at all the tyrannical deeds committed in his name.
Perhaps we should have forgone Cao Cao and entrusted someone with more prestige.
Like Yuan Chao.
Oh, just because he has money.
But I hear that Liu Bei might also be worthy.
Oh, wait.
There's me.
Well met.
On patrol, I presume?
Oh, it has grown late.
Perhaps it would be wise to leave the patrols to the troops and rest.
Speaking of which, we shall do the same.
We bid you goodnight.
Wait.
So, like...
Where did I come from?
Did I come from...
Whose room did I leave from?
Who's room did I leave from, guys?
That's the...
That real question here.
I've just received word that Lord Gong Tsun Zan was defeated by Lord Yuan Shao at I Ching.
I owed a great deal to that man.
Lord Gong Tsun Zan took me under his wing when I was directionless.
He even nominated me as a minister of Ping Yuan.
This chaos...
Has claimed a dear friend.
Oh, no.
Why weren't you there to help him?
Do not lose heart.
What kind of friend are you?
You should have died for him.
It hasn't dampened my spirits as much as you might imagine.
Lord Gong Tsun Zan's defeat has given Lord Yuan Shao the four provinces north of the river.
Making his kingdom the most powerful in the land.
Wait, Yuan Shao's the most powerful now?
Lord Cao Cao will be unavoidable.
It's time.
History is being written.
Great changes are coming to our world.
And yet I'm not part of this history for some fucking reason.
You already rolled me out.
Has been replaced by strange excitement for the future.
I have something to discuss with you.
Tonight, let us enjoy drinks in the moonlight before feasting together in your room.
Wait, in my room?
Wait, wait, what?
In the moonlight in my room?
Fade to black.
I guess we'll never know what happened in my room.
I'm not sure of his majesty's true intentions.
But, he is clearly not satisfied with the current state of affairs.
So, what say the dream deal?
Three brothers sound better for three kingdoms.
It has better marketing than four brothers.
Yeah.
Helping all those in need.
That's what you set out to do.
I'm with you no matter what, brothers.
Four is an unlucky number, Doki.
We had to get rid of you.
Four means death.
Someone had to get cut.
If his majesty is asking for help, then I want to answer the call.
That's the Liu Bei we all know.
Besides, we never plan to just keep taking orders from Tao Tao forever, right?
I have no objections.
But, how are we going to carry out such a plan?
As it stands, we are nothing more than the guests of Lord Cao Cao's.
We don't have the soldiers, let alone the support necessary to succeed.
Don't worry.
I can 1v 100,000 of them.
First of all, Lord Cao Cao's influence and claim some land on which to establish a base.
Lord Cao Cao has been talking about attacking Yuan Shu in anticipation of Yuan Shao's forces coming south.
That will be our opportunity to leave Shu City.
Our destination is in Shu, the castle at Xiaopei.
With the time we've spent there, I'm sure...
Yeah, I'm the gorilla.
I'm the gorilla, guys.
One Doki.
Versus 100,000 Chinese generals.
I don't see why we need to keep following his orders.
I understand your thoughts.
But we cannot deny that he has helped us on many occasions.
Who will win?
I'd like to repay him.
Donkey Kong is here.
One can be...
I feel the same.
You know what?
Let's...
Fuck it.
I feel the same.
That's good to hear.
Gotta make happy...
A happy general is a happy life.
It's just like you to think this way, brother.
Thank you, Kendra, for that raid.
That's the part that you admire most.
Stay true...
To your chosen path.
That's not the saying.
Before happy wife, happy life.
It was happy general, happy life.
Borrowed from Chao to defeat Yuan Shou before halting his forces in Shu province.
Meanwhile, in the city of Shu, one of the emperor's close retainers, was executed after his plans to revolt against Chao Chao were discovered.
The written agreement that bound the conspiracy together also fell into Chao Chao's hands, revealing Liu Bei's intention to rebel.
Liu Bei was left with very little time to prepare for the coming attack from Chao Chao's forces.
Country castle shall be county...
County...
Shall be commander of Shu province.
While Liu Bei is a way of negotiating the alliance with Yuan Shao, it's up to us to defend Xiaopei.
His family also resides within this castle.
Should anything happen, we must be ready to guard it with our lives.
His family?
We're his family!
What do you mean?
When did he get married?
But he might still send one of his stronger officers our way.
We need to stay on our guard.
I can't believe it.
I am sure Liu Bei and the others will be able to secure the lives.
Who needs family when you have your bros?
Exactly.
The four brothers.
All we can do is put our faith in them...
He had!
That's right!
Had!
It's not his time yet.
He needs more time with his bros, guys.
Where am I?
Did I get TP'd?
Alright, let's...
I know I'm, like, missing a...
Oh, wait.
I'm here.
Okay.
Uh...
I got the battle arts.
Ooh.
Nice.
Okay, that's related to fisting.
Alright, let's see.
Weapon shop.
Let's see if there's anything new.
Okay, none of these weapons are good, actually.
Alright.
End time.
Let's look at my super chats.
Oh, I got a new outfit.
Oh!
What outfits do I have?
Okay, let's grab some gems first, though.
Alright.
Do I have any ye olde super chats?
What is the lion armor?
Okay.
I have the uniform.
Oh, my God!
I ain't no twink no more.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that's cool.
It looks so ugly.
Okay, to be fair.
It looks like...
It looks like Zhao Yun's armor.
He's...
Look at those shoulder pads.
I'm definitely compensating for something.
You know what?
Yeah, it looks like...
It's a Zhao Yun's armor!
I knew it!
I was like, this looks like Zhao Yun's armor.
I fucking knew it.
I recognized the old main character's armor.
Like, he even has a...
That's right.
Never mind.
I might still be...
Not...
Oh, wait!
Ye olde super chat!
I'm Zhao Yun now.
Now, Toki, I'm right and thank you.
I'm a soldier fighting for Lord Liu Bei, but I wish to remain anonymous.
Once again, you have saved me.
And this time, it's from none other than Lu Bu himself.
Typically, a nameless soldier like myself would be able to do nothing but shout Lu Bu's name before being...
It's Lu Bu!
...for being struck down.
But this time, his technical blade only managed to graze my skin.
It's because you were there.
Of course, you didn't notice my presence.
Saving one ordinary soldier is nothing unusual for you.
But it's not only for me.
Your deeds have given countless common people far longer lives.
And they were fated to live.
And all of us are grateful to you for every extra day we have.
Please never forget...
Look at that, guys!
Finally!
My common people can live up to 30 instead of...
instead of 20, guys.
I did it.
Look at that.
30 years old before he...
before he dies.
I did it for him.
All right.
Let's see.
I need to figure out...
Okay.
I need to check...
Where's the map?
I need to check if I have any ye olde generals to romance.
Romance of the Three Kingdoms.
Any ye olde generals?
I know that I'm a father myself.
I finally understand.
All right.
Oh.
It's you.
All right.
Any interactions?
Oh, it doesn't look like it.
So...
No ye olde generals wants to talk to me.
Guys, I don't understand.
Where are my ye olde romance generals?
I thought we had something.
Okay.
I guess I have to go to Guan Yin.
It was like here.
Oh, wait.
But there's a...
Noink.
All right.
Go!
Hello.
Is something the matter?
Not exactly.
I am simply thinking about Liu Bei.
And where he might lead us from here.
When he told us that he had found his purpose.
When he decided to part ways with Lord Cao Cao.
To establish a base of our own.
I was happy.
If we could spare the people of this troubled world.
Even one source of grief.
Then, we sworn brothers would proudly charge into battle.
And yet, he still lacked a solid ambition for us to pursue.
He would speak of doing great things for the world.
But never decided what those great things would be.
But then, after fighting Liu Bei.
And having that discussion with Lord Cao Cao.
Something changed.
He found some sense of purpose.
This could well be the turning point.
That was, this was literally his peak in his career.
After that, it's all down.
Actually, no.
After the battle of Chibi, everything went downhill for him.
So, he still has time to peak in high school.
No matter what.
He peaked in Chibi.
I feel the same way.
So, he still has time to go up.
After that, everything was just downhill for him.
Cao Cao's forces are defensing the Xiaopei castle.
How could this be?
What about my brothers?
We have received no word.
There are rumors that they have fallen to Cao Cao's forces.
Please, sir, your orders.
Of course, we must defend the castle at all costs.
Don't worry.
You see my new armor?
It was a million dollars.
Alright.
Lubei's forces versus Chao Cao's forces.
Alright, let's see if...
Okay, what is the level for this?
Level 38.
Alright, let's grab some extra levels real quick.
We have it better than most, just being able to...
There was a...
Yeah, there you go.
How much?
Level 38.
Alright, let's grab some extra levels.
I'm gonna grab two guards with me, too.
Two dragoons...
Two lucky dragoons get to fight with me in this optional battle.
Yeah, they can't pierce...
They can't pierce this.
Oh my god, I actually look like Daoyun now.
I...
Guys, I don't remember...
What was the...
What was...
Okay, is this...
Okay.
I was gonna say, I actually don't remember...
My controls.
It's been way too long.
Oh no.
I don't remember.
Okay, it's fine.
I got it.
It's fine.
I'm figuring it out.
I'm figuring it out, guys.
Boom.
Twist.
Oh my god, I forgot.
The win.
I almost forgot.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's so fucking big.
I forgot.
I'm a short king.
The win.
Get wind.
The enemy officer...
Wait, they're preparing bullet attacks.
That's cheating.
Wait, that's cheating.
Someone is sowing chaos on the battlefield tonight.
I must stop them myself.
Okay.
No, I don't have enough win.
I don't have win attacks anymore.
This is bad.
How am I gonna use the win if I don't have...
The win?
Jesus Christ, it's a bullet.
Take this.
Oh my god.
My win is actually betraying me.
I am...
It's like, where is he going?
Where is he going?
Nice.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Wait, what...
What is my goal?
I just...
I...
Oh yeah, let me check if I have any tactics that I'm supposed to do as well.
Alright.
Who are...
None of these guys I really want to romance anyway.
So like, it doesn't really matter to me.
Alright, so...
None of these people matter.
That's fine.
Wait, I should...
Defeat...
Do I...
Hmm...
I guess I should...
Because he's still...
He's green, right?
This guy's green.
Oh, I guess.
Okay.
I need to use a sword.
Alright, where's my sword?
Where is it?
Sword time.
Okay, and then I have to use...
Uh...
What is it?
Wait, where did he go?
Okay.
LB...
Left mouse...
Y.
Okay.
Okay, LB Y sword attacks.
Okay, that's cool.
I can do that.
Now, what is my purpose?
Oh, defeat Lu Bei.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, it's just practice.
Okay, Guan Yun.
Get out of here.
That's right.
I can defeat the god of war.
Jesus.
Oh, I accidentally used my bread.
I was so confused.
I...
I got confused.
Don't worry.
I got this.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I can defeat him.
Before, he was a god.
He was a mere peasant.
Jesus Christ.
He...
Why is he...
Oh my god.
He is so strong.
I'm like doing like tickle damage right now.
Like I...
I'm barely doing anything.
Alright.
It's okay.
I'm halfway there.
I'm halfway...
Oh!
I'm gonna have to pull back.
Okay.
Um...
This is...
My guards has fled.
My...
Guys, I don't understand.
Why did you leave?
Guys!
Please.
Guys, we can't defeat Won-Yun, guys!
He's not unstoppable!
Guys, it's possible!
Don't give up!
Save yourself!
Please!
Oh, God!
Oh, my God!
Wait, what do you mean?
Where did he go?
There he is.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God!
Oh, thank God I had more soup.
Thank God.
I told you!
I told you, everyone!
We can still... Won-Yun!
Now we just need to cut off his head.
For pure accuracy.
For historical accuracy.
Wait, who's dying?
Oh, shit, he's dying.
Alright, do we save him though?
Oh, I guess... I guess we'll save him.
Alright, we didn't save him.
Now I am the new God of War.
My actual destiny.
There you go.
Eat your bread.
Eat your bread, everyone.
Nice.
Mine.
Mine now.
Boom.
Okay, have I... Did I do it?
Okay, 31.
We're almost there.
I keep using the wrong one for the horse because I'm so used to pressing...
Remember when I had to re-bind the horse?
Remember that?
Yeah.
Now I'm trying to remember to not use that button.
Cause it's not horse button.
And it's fucking me up because of it.
Alright, are you guys back?
Oh, you're back just cause I killed!
Quan Yun!
You guys came back!
Fucking cowards!
I can't believe it!
Just cause I killed Quan Yun, you came back!
Yes, we're back!
Of course we're back!
Quan Yun's dead!
Ta... Jokey.
It's called, um, Tactical Retreat.
Alright, nice.
Look at it.
Let me get him out of here.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we got... Okay, I...
I did it.
So now I can use my actual real weapon.
What was it?
It was like 224.
Alright, here we go.
Dragon's Destiny.
The real weapon is here.
Alright, get over here!
You think I'm afraid of...
Of rocks?!
That's fucking right!
Get outta here!
Wait, where are you?
Alright, nice.
This training match is a little too hardcore, Lube.
What do you mean?
I got the win!
How would I...
How can I fail if I have the power of the win on my side?
I nearly killed the God of War.
Get over here.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Get countered.
Get parried.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Win!
Your rock cannot stop me!
Oh shit, wait, who's that?
Wait, who needs help?
Oh shit.
Give me a sec.
Alright, I got help.
I got help!
Okay, who needs help?
Don't worry!
Oh my god, he's so far.
Wait, can I run past this?
Is this locked up?
Yeah, I can.
Alright, you guys don't matter.
Give me...
You guys...
Oh my god.
Guys, get out of here!
I'm trying to make sure he eats his bread!
Alright, eat your bread!
Nice.
Oh my god, he was almost dead!
You did not need my help!
Look at him!
He was one HP!
Alright.
Nice.
Jesus Christ, I better upgrade here.
I better level up after this.
With the amount of people I'm fucking beating up.
Alright, nice.
Win!
I'll never get tired of win.
With my four...
With the four elements.
Fire, rock, and wind...
Wind and...
Grass.
Doki, it's earth and air...
No, wind.
Besides, they're all dead anyway.
Alright.
Win!
Alright, nice.
We don't need water.
Okay.
All we need is these three.
Oh my god, how are you dying?!
Why is my...
Oh shit!
Why is my commander fucking fighting him?!
Oh my god, okay.
Uh...
Where's my defeat conditions?
Okay, why is he...
Okay, I guess we'll fight him.
What?
No, we don't need water.
We can just drink, like, ground water.
The retreat would be the best...
Okay.
Don't worry.
Drag wounds are here.
This tree grass...
Oh my god, you're right!
If we like...
We don't need water!
We have grass for that!
If you crush a grass plant, we'll just drink the...
We'll just drink the...
It's blood!
If you think about it...
If you think about it, if you crush...
The blood...
If you crush the blood...
Off of...
Technically, like, the innards of a grass is like...
Their blood, right?
So water...
Water is like grass...
Water is grass blood.
Yeah!
You are incredible!
You know that?
Keep doing what you're doing!
Yeah!
Cause when you rip a piece of the grass...
They have like water inside them.
And then...
It's...
It's literally...
Grass blood!
So when we drink water, we're drinking grass...
Grass blood.
All right, nice.
Just like how you drink normally.
Yeah, exactly!
I must retreat and rethink my plans.
Charge.
Okay, guys.
He's right there.
Guys!
Okay, you're useless.
I- I- I- Jeckos!
You are actually...
He gets paid.
He's not good in a fight.
He's like right there.
Guys are like, I got you!
Dohki, I got you!
The enemy officer...
Has been defeated.
Oh, I didn't measure the range!
You know, you guys could, like, look backwards.
Alright, nice.
That should be a level up, right?
Yeah.
Yeah!
Nice, plus 37.
Alright, uh, what was this one over here?
Name is here to hold more.
Okay, we don't need that.
We need defense.
So that I can get the bread.
Bread is more important.
Doki likes to break the... Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Papa Smir, thank you for the super chat.
Doki pays us in Mantle.
And it's shocked that there's not enough for us to fight the God of War.
Oh, great.
I got two more guides to, like, not do their jobs.
Alright.
Blunting enemy attacks and reducing damage.
That's what I need, guys.
Uh... Wait, actually, do I have anyone else I need to talk to?
Since it's, like, a new objective?
Let's double check.
I just want to double check if there's anyone that wants to talk to me.
Oh, I did it!
Oh, just because I... Yeah, I did his mission.
Okay.
Djinn province.
Oh, there's another one over here.
Alright, what's the recommended level?
39 already?
Alright, let's... I don't want to deal with that.
Okay, what was it?
Djinn?
Djinn... G... Sli... Djinn.
Okay, there.
Jesus Christ.
But where?
Where in Djinn?
You guys... You guys... Okay, you guys are very useful, but definitely not in a fight.
I'm sorry, Djinn.
I will not call on you for a fight.
I...
Alright.
You're right.
The dating sim portion of this should let me...
Should let me gain XP.
What the heck?
Okay.
Prove me wrong.
Prove me wrong that you guys are useful in a fight.
Let's keep up with your weapon maintenance.
Prove me wrong.
You're not trusting your life to that thing after all.
Sorry.
We can't.
Oh, there he is.
I'm just fucking finding this guy.
Yeah.
No.
Hello.
I did your stupid mission thing.
Oh, it's been some time since we met.
Do you remember me?
Sorry.
Djinn was there.
I could never forget you.
Jesus Christ.
Look, it is very hard to remember you when you were standing next to, like, the dragon himself.
Really?
I thought there was a good chance you wouldn't remember.
I was so certain we'd meet again.
I like how he's like, do you remember me?
Sadly looks to the left.
It's reached my ears that you now serve Lord New Bay.
Is that right?
I've just been wandering the land without aim.
But you, you're different.
You've been fulfilling your role as a guardian of peace.
That's me.
Don't you serve anyone?
That's quite a difficult question for me.
I studied under Master Shui Jing, a teacher to many talented individuals.
Shui Jing.
And in order to keep up with them, I've had to make immense effort.
Now, however, I find myself facing a dilemma.
Which path will resolve the turmoil plaguing the land, yet also lead to a better future?
If what I've heard on my travels is accurate, either Lord Cao Cao or Lord Yuan Shao...
You're wearing green.
We all know where you're gonna join.
Still, I refuse to give up...
We know where you're going.
You don't have to pretend.
But...
I am nobody.
If I actually had talent...
Perhaps I could help Lord Buu Bae find a path to victory.
You should at least try...
You are capable of it.
I believe so.
I see now...
I gotta give him the confidence.
I apologize.
There was no need to burden you with my personal worries.
Lassen rubs his head.
Shit.
Bites his lip.
I feel the urge to show my true self instead of keeping...
When I'm with you, I feel the urge to show my true...
Oh my god!
Bro!
What are these lines?
I'm glad I found you.
I feel he helped me clarify my dreams.
It's my eyes.
Yeah, he's looking to my eyes.
I think I shall end my travel soon.
Oh my god.
Then, I'll pledge my services to Lord Buu Bae...
And present him with my strategy for victory.
I did it.
I'd appreciate your patience until then.
I look forward to us serving him together.
With my charms, I have recruited another general to Buu Bae's army.
How could he fuck up now?
How could Buu Bae fuck up with all these talented generals I recruited?
Surely he's gonna win the Three Kingdoms War.
Alright, more.
Out of seven battle art chains to feed 200 enemies with a charged strong attack.
To feed 200 foes with charged strong...
Oh, Jesus Christ.
I've been completely immersed in a diligent study.
Allow me to share the fruits of my scholarship with you.
That's all I can do to be of use of Lu Bae now.
Surely, right guys?
Surely you can't fuck this up.
The children remain innocent and unflappable.
Alright, let's go back to...
Let's go back here.
Alright, I need to check what my...
What my destiny stuff is.
Okay, I don't know what dramatic success of a tactic one time.
Like, what is that?
I don't understand what this is from Peng Tong.
Alright, uh...
What else?
Jesus, there's so many I haven't talked to.
Uh, battle art chains.
Uh...
Okay, we'll focus on...
Okay, he wants me to pull a paddle.
And using a lance.
Okay, we'll use a lance.
Alright.
Never mind.
We're not using a...
All of my weapons fucking sucks.
Ah!
Okay, we'll use a lance first.
So guys, what is firing enemies down?
Oh, from a height.
Okay.
I will definitely not do that.
Oh.
This might be an issue.
Roy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So we pay Peng Tong to rank up our bonds.
Let's make him our wingman.
Most fucking expensive wingman.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lu Bei jump there, leaving Sha Pi to ally with Yuan Shao's forces.
In their absence, the defense of Shao Pi's castle falls to me.
Not only is this castle the base from which Lu Bei's destiny will take flight, it is a place his family members call home.
Which I...
Why I am certain my sworn brothers will return.
And why I am determined to guard this castle with my life.
First, we must rout the enemy trying to breach these walls.
Then we shall cut down the advancing invaders with the castle to our back.
Faced with the reality of Shao Tao's forces, even I find myself stunned at the audacity of the fear we're about to attempt.
Yet, attempt it we must.
And I truly believe we can succeed.
To that end, I entrust my back to you.
Just like when we first met, Guan Yun.
That's right.
When you face the government army.
With my blade at his command, Lu Bei shall protect the future.
Alright.
Begin the battle.
Two gorillas.
Who will win?
Two gorillas versus Shao Tao's army.
That's right.
Wait, what was my objective for this?
I forgot.
Alright, let's see.
With charge attacks.
Okay.
How do I use it?
Oh, this is the charge attack.
Okay.
I was like, where the fuck is the charge?
Jesus Christ.
Weapon fucking sucks.
There you go.
Alright, guys.
I'm not using this.
This weapon actually sucks.
This weapon is so bad.
Give me back Dragoon Destiny.
Alright.
Oh my god.
That's so much more damage.
Alright.
Sorry.
No romancing for him for now.
Alright.
We met with our blades.
Is he okay?
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
Wait, how do I get over there?
Oh, I have to go outside.
Whoops.
Okay, give me a sec.
I fucked up.
He might be dead.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
The other guy might be dead to the right.
I swear I read the wrong way.
I'm sorry.
Where is he advancing?
Oh, wait.
He's gonna fucking die.
As long as I'm here, you won't get through.
Oh my god!
Eat your bread!
I did it.
I'm a hero.
Be a hero.
Nice.
The enemy officer has been a great help indeed.
Allow us to defend the gate.
Alright.
And then, how do we get to the next side?
Where did I go wrong?
Oh, shit!
Don't worry!
I'm coming over!
So you've got... Eat your bread!
Eat your bread!
Sorry, but your help is needed here.
Alright, nice.
I would be honored.
If I could test my skills.
Win!
Oh, shit.
Okay, I thought you would get hit by the winner earlier.
Nice.
Alright.
Alright, he's almost dead, guys.
Halfway is almost, right?
Halfway is technically... ALMOST!
God, I love the wind fight.
The wind is so strong.
Holy fuck.
I already broke his armor again.
That's actually crazy.
How fast the wind is.
What would you do against the wind?
Nothing!
Get out of here!
What?
You're still alive?
What the fuck?
Get out of here!
Get out!
You're not the main character here!
Well, I still can.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh, shit.
Is that another general coming over?
No, leave.
Oh, wait.
There is.
But that's just, like, one guy.
It's fine.
Alright, guys.
This is it!
Use your arrows!
Win!
Oh, my god.
He instantly died.
Oh, that was fast.
Okay.
I was not expecting him to die that fast.
That's right.
Boom!
Easiest fucking fight of my life.
Alright, guys.
Who are you gonna charge this time?
Okay, the general is right here, but that's okay.
That's okay.
You guys missed the general yet again, but that's okay.
I believe in you.
I hate it.
See you were useful in, right?
Let's test that theory first.
Test what theory?
Wait, what?
Oh, no.
They're doing what I've done last time!
Using my strategy against me?!
That's illegal!
They're stealing my strats!
Oh, shit.
I'm blocking Guan Yu.
Wait, who?
Why can't he just do that?!
They can just do that?!
Steal my strategy?!
I cop- I padded it!
It's copyrighted to me!
She- you didn't copy- you didn't copyright your strats!
How was I supposed to do?!
They could just steal it!
Oh, no.
Okay, we gotta go back again.
Alright.
Wait, do I have to kill- Wait, who?
Again?
I- I just left!
What the fuck?!
The resistance cannot last forever.
So, what am I going to do with you?
Okay.
And I thought they'd come marching in with a huge army.
Okay, nice.
That's right.
We don't need a- we don't need a big army!
We just need two gorillas!
Me and Quan Yun!
No,
no.
No, no.
No, no!
No.
This is the Gorilla situation.
No!
No, no!
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Wait!
All right.
But- for real- Ha-ha!
Does it look like a hundred guys are gonna be crucified?
Are you going to win this?
I don't think so.
Still, he must be getting quite nervous under these circumstances.
Let's take advantage of the situation while he's on the back foot.
Alright, nice.
Jesus Christ, they're sending more?
The enemy formation has changed.
Perhaps he could approach the enemy's stronghold now.
Oh no, he's getting overconfident.
Oh no, Guan Yu, stop!
You're getting overconfident, Guan Yu!
No!
You're not the strategist!
Guan Yu, stop!
I'm still needed.
And that means I must fall back for now.
Looks like it worked.
Now, it's time to put an end to Guan Yu.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Guys!
We will change history!
I was more than ready for a trap.
Wait!
I'll cleave my way through and bring us as much closer to the people.
Did we change history?
We saved him?
With this, we have put Guan Yu in the back.
Oh wait, shit.
Let me uh...
Shall we initiate the advance?
Oh god.
God.
If the castle falls, all of this will be for naught.
Guan Yu, please!
All we can do now is fight the foes before us.
Alright, we got rid of him.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Now believe in your allies and in our victory to come.
Jesus Christ, you're so many!
You need two gorillas!
I'm the second gorilla!
I'm coming over!
Don't worry!
The second gorilla!
I can't!
There's too many people!
Wait, I did it.
Wait, no.
Okay.
I didn't do it.
There's still more.
There's more coming in.
I trust Quan.
Oh yeah!
What about me?
Guys, guys!
I'm part of- I'm part of the Quan Yu army too, guys.
What about me?
The enemy officer has been defeated.
I'm here too, guys.
I'm here too.
Wait, you are?
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm ready to face you.
Your design is so boring.
I'm definitely- You have like three shields.
Like, I'm not scared.
You have three shields.
There we go.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
So that I may fight again.
Why are you fighting one guy?
I fought like 20!
Guys, and you're still cheering for him?
I literally fought 20 generals!
Alright.
Let's move, brother.
That's fucked up.
You know what I'm most insecure about.
You know this is my insecurity!
That doesn't matter.
It's not just one guy.
How am I still fighting?
Alright.
Time to attack.
Nice.
Okay.
Zero time.
Nice.
Alright.
That's fucking right!
No it won't!
I'm still going!
That's fucking right!
Get out of here!
What, what, what the fuck?
Who interrupted my fight?
He's fucking interrupted!
I shall analyze later, but now I must pull back.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
My mission is far from complete.
There's still more?
I have no choice but to retreat now.
Alright.
That's fine.
Turn the tables.
That's fine!
Wind!
Random drive by spirit.
Wait.
And Gwanyu didn't even defeat him!
He fucking ran away!
I defeated all my generals!
Time to act?
I think I might be the...
Oh my god.
He just ran...
What?
He just ran off?
He just...
He just ran away from...
Wait!
Where are you going?
He just ran away from my wind!
He's like...
He drove away!
You can do that?
You can just run away?
Get back!
It's called...
A tactical retreat!
You can just do that?
Hehehehe!
That's possible?
Alright.
Nice.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
Give me a sec!
There's so many!
I like...
I don't know what's going on anymore.
Better back off.
Okay.
We've broken through!
This is our chance!
What do you mean this is your...
I'm so...
Oh my god!
Gwanyu, come back!
Gwanyu, don't!
Come back!
I need help!
Help!
Don't fight!
Don't!
I need help!
Gwanyu!
Please!
I've proved I'm a true warrior.
Come back here!
I'm still fighting!
What do you mean?
No help!
Hahaha.
I'm still trying to kill him!
Goyun, please!
Jesus Christ, I don't want Fred anymore.
It's fine.
Okay, why is that so loud?
No help, he really wants that.
Goyun, he's literally coming to me!
He's literally coming over!
Goyun, please!
The enemy officer had so much fun.
But it seems...
He's finally... He's only coming over because Shao Udun is heading to me.
Alright.
That's right, it's me.
It's me!
It was always me!
Alright.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Jesus Christ!
I'm heading over!
Oh, shit!
There he is!
Goyun, please!
Get over here!
Hahaha!
Thanks, there's so many!
I'm sorry.
I'm going to withdraw!
What do you mean?
Dragon!
That's it.
I'm going in.
I told you.
I told you this was basically...
Jesus Christ.
You broke through that encirclement.
That's fucking right.
This is the gorilla situation.
I told you.
What do you mean, Goyun?
What do you mean, Goyun?!
I'm 1v7ing!
Why is it always Goyun?!
Alright.
Why is it always Quanyu?
Why does no one ask about Doki?
I don't understand!
He's Quanyu, he did so much.
I never moved from this spot.
No!
I would have saved my musu if I knew!
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Okay, this is... you can't fuck this up.
You can't fuck this up, guys.
You literally can't fuck this up.
You can't fuck this up!
I jumped out!
Wait, everybody's dead.
Okay.
Where is he?
Where is Guanyu?
Guys, I think you guys just all died.
Zero out of 17.
Um, you guys actually all died.
I like walked around him and you all died.
Whoopsie!
I just let him musu all of you.
This is all... this is... this was your dead bodies.
Right here.
No chance of winning.
What?
One of the drag wounds that died.
Right here.
Yeah, wait, what?
Wait, what?
It's not over?
Oh wait!
We better retreat for now and bolster the castles that...
We still have information.
No matter how many people you throw at me.
As long as I draw breath...
You killed one guy!
And he tactically retreated!
Alright, nice.
I get more... the... why, why, why, why, why thrusts.
Okay, level 41.
Yay!
Level 20, horse!
More buns.
Uh, Lush knocks nearby enemies off balance.
That's not how history sees it.
I was part of the history!
Anton, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
When you, when he wrote the game, they were thinking of a certain market share.
I think, say, Doki, what's your opinion on beefcake historical Chinese warriors who talk about their feelings?
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
I should have went to the Sun class.
Such spirit!
I can't believe Gwanyun saved everyone!
Oh!
Guess who's not in this cutscene!
Yet again!
Lord Gwanyu!
Look at that Gwanyun doing all the work!
Look at him go!
The castle has already fallen!
Surrender at once!
What do you mean?
I killed 20 generals!
How did we lose the castle?
I should fight...
To my last breath!
When you beat a thousand enemies!
Oh, Gwanyun!
You are the strongest!
You would dishonor yourself!
Out of stubborn pride!
You would let Liu Bei family die?
Breaking your vow to your sworn brothers that you would die together!
Damn!
Defying your duty to protect that which Liu Bei entrusted to you!
They never even died together anyway!
Would your honor...
Truly allow that?
I was actually like fighting my...
My demons...
My mind...
I need...
Three promises from you!
During that, I thought I was fighting 20 generals, but he locked me into like a padded room!
I will surrender...
To the Emperor...
Not to Lord...
Cao Cao!
No harm...
Shall come to the family condiciones of Liu Bei..
And the moment...
I find those brothers, I shall run to their side!
I shall run to their side!
Uh huh!
You have my word!
I...
Shall convey your wishes to...
I accept those terms!
Oh my god!
So how?
How outstanding!
To have a renowned hero...
Such as you, on our side.
This is the one time Guan Yun was in his army.
Where he was blue.
May our acquaintance be long and fruitful.
Taucha has always had, like, this, like, lifelong crush on Guan Yun for the longest time.
He was, like, that ga- that girl, like, looking in the side and be like, I hope Senpai would notice me.
And he would, like, stalk him all the time.
Wait, so what happens to me?
What happens to me?
Oh, am I, like, just, like, his plus one?
Like, I'm just his plus one?
If Guan Yun joins, I have to be dragged along.
Hey, I'm here too, Tao Tao.
Packed deal.
What do
you mean?
Yes.
I would like for Guan Yun to eventually come under my command.
He's like, chaperone on that.
I want him to walk with the path to the path to the path.
I'm not allowed to go around without an adult.
I will stay by my brother's side for as long as I draw breath.
And what if Liu Bei is no longer of this world?
Hey,
I'm here, too.
We'll ask my opinion whether or not we'll join your army.
Hey, I'm here, too, guys!
He has been incredibly generous.
And has treated Liu Bei's family well.
Shh!
Doki, the adults are talking.
That is a bet I must repay in full before I leave.
But I do not intend to stay here long.
I will leave.
As soon as I know where my brother has gone.
No matter how many losses he suffers, or how weak he becomes, my brother is the only one that can bring salvation to the victims of our troubled times.
I truly believe that.
Not so dead, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Well...
We're in Tao Tao's army now.
Good thing I have Liu.
Good thing I have...
I never expected you to fall back under my influence.
Oh, hey!
Yay!
Oh, now we have a private one-to-one conversation after you didn't talk to me before.
I was certain we would never get another chance to meet like this.
I'm like his rebound.
After Guanyu rejected him.
But now, when you and Guanyu have fallen right into my hands.
I can think of no greater gift.
And now he wants me.
Fuck it, I'm happy to be here.
Don't fall for it.
Shh, don't tell Liu Bei.
Are you?
Well, it's good that you've made up your mind.
After the loss of Sharpay.
Don't fall for it.
You may stay here for as long as you wish.
Of course, if you're already determined to stay, I'd much rather you remain permanently in my service.
In any case, I see no reason to keep you under guard.
I promise you will be treated with all the respect a guest is due.
That's why I'm wearing blue and green, guys.
Never trust the uniform.
I'm not saying that we will also be well taken care of.
I wouldn't dare disrespect your loyalty to him.
Get some rest for now, Zuluan.
May your next journey be fruitful.
And hopefully, at my side.
Why didn't you talk to me like that when Guan Yin was here?
Finally found myself a job.
I don't understand, huh?
I was right there, but he didn't talk to me like that before.
All right, let's see.
Things have gotten so much better.
All right, what does Chow Chow want?
He was shy.
I was the rebound because Guan Yin said no.
He treated me like a fucky rebound.
They must be trying to quash our potential strategies with sheer numbers.
Be that as it may, any commander who would lead such a massive army is bound to let his hubris get the better of them.
We must discover and strike at where they have been negligent.
Hmm.
The question is, how?
Send a small force to ambush them.
No.
It would be but a momentary diversion against an army that large.
Though if we can separate their forces, we may be able to take them down one group at a time.
Separate them how?
I doubt you and Chow would be easily fooled.
If one wants to catch a catfish sleeping at the bottom of a pond, one must use valuable bait.
Ooh.
Bait?
Yeah.
Very well.
I will join the assault.
Oh!
We're going to use Chow Chow's bait.
This town has gotten bigger.
Chow Chow's forces.
Oh, wait.
You have received a letter.
A letter?
Whenever Lord Quo-Chow does.
That's a letter.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Whose letter is it?
I just got a letter.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's just my doctor who's sitting right beside me.
I must mention that your stomach seems all but indestructible.
Whether it's slurring up filthy pond water, scarfing down unknown species of mushrooms, or sinking your teeth into a half-cooked meal.
Wait, where am I in the reading?
Nothing ever appears to affect you.
I see people like this from time to time.
They've built up resilience to all sorts of things by surviving in the harshest conditions.
The thing is that medicine tests do not do much for them either.
So as a doctor, I need to be careful when working with them.
I bet you're nearly immune to poison as- How would you know that?
Have you- Did you try to poison me?
How do you know if I'm nearly immune to poison?
We never tested that out.
But it wouldn't make much sense to have you ingest some just to check.
So we'll never be sure.
Sure, you never tested it on me.
That said, we can submerge that yet perhaps been gradually exposed to various hazards from a young age to train your body to resist their effects.
I don't know.
I don't trust my my child doctor.
I don't think I trust him guys.
Why did he say I'm nearly immune to poison?
How would he know?
All right, let us see.
Let us see if we have any- Any interactions with people.
All right, we don't.
It's sad.
I know there was a- There was like a mini- Oh, there it is.
Is it still love 39?
Or is it correlate to what- No, it is still love 39.
That's good.
All right, this is time to train.
All right, that's good.
So I can actually do these objectives now.
All right, let's see.
Achieve dramatic success with a- Achieve- What is battle art chain, guys?
I don't remember what battle art chain is because it doesn't tell me either.
All right, battle art chain.
Uh, defeat 100 foes with sword.
I will never talk to these people again.
I don't know.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks.
Oh, use a battle art when it's blue.
Oh, with the generals.
Okay, I get it.
I know.
All right, you defeat 50 enemies with a staff.
Okay, this last thing is so hard.
Using a- This one is hard.
Okay.
Uh, do I have like good ones?
Oh my god, I hate them.
I hate them.
Okay.
Uh, I guess I'll use- Do I have anything with- I don't want to romance him.
He's too old.
He's like a grandpa.
I feel awkward about that.
Nah, that's fine.
We don't need grandpa.
That- Have I ever completed Yuan Shao's shit?
Is that the only Yuan Shao thing I need to do?
Okay.
We're fully charged.
Okay, fully charged strong attacks.
Okay.
Hot, uh, okay.
Oh, nice.
Okay, strong attack.
We can do this.
He's an awesome grab- Look, we have a lot of choices, okay?
So I can- I can actually pick and choose.
I- I- So it's fine.
I can actually pick and choose.
Okay, nice.
Wait, there's someone behind me.
There's someone behind me, isn't there?
Actually- Oh, shit.
That's a Liga.
Boom!
Nice.
All right, let's get rid of him.
Jesus Christ.
Stop trying to kill me!
It don't matter!
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh my god, please.
I'm trying to kill this one guy right now.
You're not that important!
Jesus Christ.
This guy is so annoying.
He has too much HP.
Boom!
Only 451, really?
I thought you were doing more!
All right.
Goodbye.
Jesus, this guy was so strong.
The enemy officer.
For no reason.
All right, now I can.
Oh, shit.
Please, let me use my attack!
I can't complete this!
Oh my god!
I can't complete this one thing I wanted to do.
All right.
Okay, now I'll do the thing.
This is not fair.
All right.
I give up.
Fuck it.
This guy has been annoying me.
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna kill him fast.
This guy has been so annoying.
He doesn't deserve it.
The rest of the people, I don't need a romance.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Get out of here!
Try and kill this one guy!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I'm in a corner.
Guys, I'm in a corner.
Okay.
That's fine.
Shoot the arrow on my end.
Arch-dragons, I believe.
Okay.
One down.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Where is he?
What the fuck?
What's he gonna do?
Oh, shit!
That's what he's gonna do.
Oh my god!
You just...
You guys just all died.
Whoops!
Oh.
Oh, you guys are all dead.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
Jesus, please!
Stop!
Please!
Oh my god, the big fucking...
I'm trying to kill him!
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Nice.
Parried.
Win never betrays me!
Jesus.
Okay, all of these officers are like so...
So tanky, too.
That's the worst part.
They're all so tanky.
Oh, they're all advancing!
Nice.
Oh my god, this is my last raid, too.
Win!
Get hit!
Get win!
Hey, nice.
I just hate how tanky they all are.
They're all so tanky, so it takes like fucking forever to kill them.
Let's get serious.
Oh my...
That's it!
Falling back.
I'm mad!
Sometimes I couldn't be of more assistance.
I'm mad now!
I'm mad!
Bear witness to my power.
I'm so mad!
Am I gonna reach them?
I...
I don't even know if I reached them.
That's it.
You're taught this!
Wait.
It's dual time.
You'll keep me amused, I hope.
Thank god.
Thank fucking god.
I was so done.
Thank god.
Good.
You can't kill me if you're stuck in the wind.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
I think I hit.
That's too busy trying to...
Trying to call the wind.
I'm gonna fight back.
The enemy officer is undefeated.
Okay.
You must push harder.
Alright, nice.
I got like...
I don't have to deal with that.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Did he just kick me?
What's wrong with you?
Use your fucking weapon!
Time to act.
Oh my god, how is he still...
Get out!
Oh my god!
Stop!
It's a 1v1!
Respect a 1v1!
That's what you get for not respecting.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Nice.
Jesus.
These guys are all so fucking tanky.
I had to fight like 10 of them.
Alright.
How good I am!
I don't even level up from that?
Are you serious?
Okay, I thought I would level up.
From, like, the amount of shit I just did?
Okay, we're strong attack using Pado.
Okay, I still need to do the Pado thing.
Pado?
Nice.
I got two extra guards.
All right.
Okay.
Is this where I have to go?
Tao Tao's first forces versus Yuan Shao.
Where's the other?
Wait, don't I have another one?
Is that it?
Is that the only one I have?
Pado Yang province.
I guess that's the only one I have.
All right.
It says Lu Bei, but I'm pretty sure this just read...
This was called Tao Tao right here.
All right, this time I can use...
I can use the skysplitter this time.
Then I have Guan Yun by my side.
Nothing can stop me.
Yeah, but then why do you say Bracket...
Bracket...
Lu...
Lu Bei?
All right.
Yun Shao has moved his army separate from He Bei with the intention of subjugating to Lord Tao Tao and claiming the land for himself.
And they plan on starting with Baima Castle.
The army surrounded the place and they're practically clamping...
Oh my god.
That is a lot.
That's why we'll take out the commander, Yang Ling.
Protecting Baima will assure our victory right at the onset.
We're obviously done for.
We lose Xiao Xiao.
So this plan turns that logic on its head.
Lord Xiao Xiao will be acting as a decoy, drawing Yang Li away...
away from the castle towards Yang Jing.
At the encircling breaks, a detachment will come cut down Yang Ling.
I suggest Yang Liao and Lord Guan Yu are the right men for the job.
Understood.
I shall commit the totality of my strength to the task.
I shall use this battle to repay the hospitality Lord Tao Tao has shown me.
Even spread thin, the enemy has overwhelming numbers in Baima.
A surprise attack will work well to willow them down.
But to keep Yuan Xiao's forces around the castle unaware, we'll have to dispose of any foes on the road without most haste.
To ensure successful ambush, we must also assist.
Yang Jing with considerable forces.
To pull this off on both fronts, our reinforcements must be accurate and adaptable.
Alright.
You can leave it to me.
This is the extent of our strategy.
Lord Tao Tao, I will return the floor to you.
Indeed, the battle against Yuan Xiao has only just begun.
We must start off strong to gain and maintain the upper hand.
I'm ready to put my life on the line to win this battle.
I hope I can count all of you...
Oh yes, nice.
That's right.
I have Guan Yun by my side.
I have the God of War now.
Nothing can stop me.
Alright.
Get my force in here.
And if Tao Tao unfortunately dies, so be it.
Surely it was just destiny, right?
Wait, what?
Oh, yo, you're not getting away.
What are you gonna do?
Run away with your fucking legs?
That's right.
I have a horse.
You can't get away from me.
You can form the main force of our position.
We will lose the advantage.
That's right.
Quickly, pursue them.
We will keep the enemy at bay.
That's right.
You thought you can get away.
You have legs.
I have a horse.
Who's level 20.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
That was easy.
Okay, one more.
Whoops.
Alright, there you go.
He's dead.
There we go, guys.
Look at that.
It was just that easy.
Okay, I...
Literally, it was that easy.
Alright, see?
Look at that.
He tried to run without a horse.
So foolish.
Let's go!
Here's our chance.
Take the enemy by surprise.
That's right.
They'll never expect this.
Forces lies in their inexhaustible numbers.
Woo!
They seem to be pouring out from the fort in an endless stream.
Wait, are they all dead?
We should first focus our efforts on taking the fort.
That will force them to change their strategy.
Wait, these are all weak-ass generalists.
What the fuck?
My enemy officer advance has been defeated.
They're all so weak.
They're actually all so weak.
Look at them.
They're like jello.
Allied forces are marching to our aid.
This will be enough to break the siege.
Stand strong.
They're like all jello.
The victory is imminent.
Can't believe this.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
You guys are all jello.
I'm an officer.
Oh shit.
We're on our way out of a tight spot.
Don't let up now.
Lloyd's out sounds renowned.
Don't worry.
What the fuck?
Just look at the size of the force they've sent after him.
You think you can get away?
Many of their soldiers here.
That's fucking right.
Is to do all that we can to protect...
Get out of here.
You thought those shields are gonna do anything?
A great debt of gratitude.
This battle is my chance to end with my blade.
Get out of here.
This is the fate of all who oppose me.
I did it.
I did a chain.
Everybody's dead, but I did it.
Oh wait, I should get over.
Wait, somebody's inside.
Wait, how did they get inside?
Wait, how the fuck did they get inside?
Get out of here!
You're not supposed to be inside!
Get out!
Wait, what?
We are providing aid in this battle in accordance with our pledge to the people of the north.
Huh?
However, seeing as Cao Cao is loyal to the Han court, we have no objections to taking his life.
What?
Wait.
Wait, he's me!
Hey, what the fuck?
Oh, no.
Wait, but I have to kill him!
Oh, don't worry.
Cao Cao will be okay, right?
Guys, do you think Cao Cao will be...
Really?
Who is that?
Is that the shadow?
Oh my god, is that shadow to my Sonic?
This is not fair.
I have to kill him.
Oh my god, he is shadow.
Oh my god.
Do you not know who you are or from where you hail, but you seem to be driven by a strong conviction.
Your power alone is insufficient for a comeback.
Oh my god, it is shadow!
Not Toki versus...
Oh my god, more like silver.
Wait, is that a shadow or silver?
Oh my god, silver.
Get out of here!
That's right!
Wait, okay.
I should change weapons.
Alright.
Wait, did I finish it?
Sorry.
Sorry, silver.
Let me...
This is much more important.
I need to figure out if I need to keep using this.
Okay, I do.
Okay.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm still here.
Sorry, I had to figure out if I could still use this.
Alright, nice.
Bye.
Oh my god, I got extreme musu!
Sorry, I had to check my to-do list.
I couldn't finish up.
This is the fate of all you oppose me.
Alright.
Stay busy.
I shall put an end to you with my intellect.
That's fucking right.
Swirl!
Oh my god.
Wrong way.
Ha ha ha ha.
Come on, you're one-hit!
Yes!
That's fucking right.
Get out!
Shadow!
Has been defeated.
Of the sacred bird, Luan.
Good.
Alright, we did it.
Yes.
You must be.
It's me.
Let's go.
Yes.
It's me.
Brutal.
I don't know how much more I can take.
Alright, it's fine.
He doesn't matter.
Hmm.
We should stop here to assess the situation.
I can't hold on much longer.
Wait, ready to charge?
We need a way through.
Let's start the advance.
Who is ready?
Bro, I...
There's so many people I have to worry about!
Let's start the advance.
I have to go back?
I have to go back.
I went the wrong way.
I got confused!
How was I supposed to know?
Jesus Christ.
Alright, sound, sound.
Charge!
Do your thing!
Wait, you didn't even need me there!
Jesus Christ, you didn't even need me there!
What do you mean capture it in our back?
I just captured this!
Okay, whoops, I accidentally used my musu again.
That's my bad.
Alright.
Can't the enemy do better than that?
I'm so confused.
There's so many people I have to fight.
Oh!
There's too many places!
Who died?
Oh, no.
Please!
Everyone, stop dying!
I need you all to stop dying!
Alright, that's fine.
All right.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
All right, we got this guy out of the way.
Get out of here.
All right.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
There we go.
He's dead, too.
Resistance has been defeated.
Let's go.
Oh, no.
I'll come back.
I'm going back and forth.
I don't know where to go.
There's too many.
Too many fights.
One at a time.
Please.
One at a time, everybody.
Oops.
I need to fall back.
I need everybody to chill right now.
Just the right time.
Quickly.
Lend us a hand.
All right.
I'm starting to get fatigued.
Who is?
I've been waiting for this.
Jesus Christ.
Let's go.
To the right time...
Oh my God.
lower left base.
Guys!
There's so many.
We should attack now.
We should attack now!
Oh my God.
The enemy officer.
Has been defeated.
What do you mean, we should attack now?
Wait for me!
Okay.
All right.
Wait for me, Sansa!
It's not time yet!
I'm still fighting!
All right, nice.
That's good.
That kills more time for me.
Who?
Who are you?
All right.
What do you mean you're one of his greatest?
Who are you?
Never even heard of you in my life!
If you truly are his greatest warrior, you'd have a custom cosmetic.
I can't believe this.
That's fucking right.
The enemy is not doing well.
Has been defeated.
Keep it going.
I have to be arrested.
Let's go.
How can this be?
Oh, we did it.
It's fine.
I can't believe we managed to drive back such a large force.
We may be outnumbered.
Coming back, guys.
Coming back!
I'm here, everyone!
I'm here!
Don't die!
Take your brain!
All right.
Did I finish?
Sorry.
This is much more important than I finish.
All right.
We're almost there.
Nice.
Our next target will likely be the enemy forces at Yem-jin.
Go, Guan Yu, go!
That's right!
With all your might, Guan Yu!
Jesus Christ!
Oh, my God!
There's fucking chariots everywhere again!
Oh, man!
Normally, one seeks to overcome their opponent on the battlefield through superior resources.
You, on the other hand...
Okay, nice.
Jesus, I'm killing the enemies.
I'm just doing them non-stop right now.
A thousand!
Yeah, I know I should adjust the skills, but like, I don't care.
I'm just literally my, like, object- oh my god.
The fucking chariots.
Oh my god.
The STUPID CHARIOTS!
Oh my god, where are they?
Where is the chariots?
I'm trying to find the chariots!
Where are they?
Oh my god, this is- this is fucked up.
This is actually fucked up.
I can't- this is so fucked up.
This is so fucked up cuz I don't know where they are.
This is so fucked up.
Where- I'm lagging cuz I don't know where the chariots are!
Like, I can't tell!
I- Why is the chariots?
There's too many!
Where is this- OH MY GOD!
My chariots can't handle it!
I can't handle it!
I can't- I'm trying so hard!
To find- I can't- I can't- I can't- I can't- I can't- it's like- where- there's so many going on!
It's actually- it's actually impossible!
Guan Yun!
I can't handle it.
You gotta find- you gotta find the chariots for me, Caien!
You gotta find it!
Okay, there we go!
I- Awesome!
This is the one you and gouf to destroy the chariots!
Holy shit!
My game was like- where- bahy g Game couldn't handle it either.
That's crazy.
Bro, my game wasn't getting fucked up there.
He was so confused.
He also was like, where the fuck is the Chariot?
There's no way I don't defeat 300 enemies from here.
Oh my god!
That was fast.
Jesus, 400?!
Get out of here!
Alright.
There we go.
Okay, sure.
I mean, he's so cool.
Any who believe themselves worthy may test their might against me.
That's actually crazy, though.
I was like, where is... I can't see anything.
There were so many people on my screen.
Even my PC was like, whoa, calm down.
Calm the fuck down.
What?
Why did it happen like this?
We fucking did it.
This is a new benchmark game.
I think they put like, 6,000 people in that army right there.
I was like, what if the... the chariot was like, five gigabytes each.
I could foresee losing either Yanliang or Wenchou, but for both to have been slain.
You fought well this time, Cao Cao.
But, this brings you no closer to matching our might.
In the end, there can only be one victor.
And that will be me!
This encounter is 50 chariots.
Winning the first battle bodes very well for our side.
But overcoming their greater numbers will prove to be difficult.
This is not where we will strike the final blow.
But we killed so many!
Why are we walking away?
We killed so many!
I did so much there!
How are we running away?
Nice.
Alright, we got that.
We got that.
Nice.
I know we got another one that was close too.
Oh yeah, we almost got that.
We needed 200.
Uh, 200 and...
Yeah, that was nice.
Alright, we'll get that.
The homework never ends.
This was a great victory.
And it is owed to your wisdom and strength.
Ice Leung is strong?
Oh, is that what my skill moves?
But it is not yet over, my lord.
Alright, I'll equip that next.
Thanks.
Okay, but is it better than Wen though?
It looks like Yuan Shao is continuing his march south.
They will overrun us if we do not intercept them.
To defeat a large army, we must first take advantage of the terrain.
It's better than Wen?
We will draw back the front line to Grandu.
Wen has been with...
Wen helped us beat LuPu.
Wen has never let me down.
Okay, but Wen helped me beat LuPu.
You can't say it's not that good if I beat LuPu with it.
Did someone call for me?
Yeah, Wen has Wen in it.
Checkmate.
Wait.
Hello?
Who's there?
Shadow?
Zuluwan, it's been too long.
So it really was you.
I never would have expected this.
But why didn't you tell me where you were?
Who are you?
Shadow, that you?
What are you saying, Zuluwan?
Wait, is that the little kid?
You've forgotten who I am.
Is he a big boy now?
You won't answer?
Or maybe you can't.
Then it's true.
You really have forgotten everything.
You mean you weren't a little boy?
I suppose I should have known.
If you had your memories, you wouldn't have allied yourself with Tsao Tsao, the usurper of the Han.
You have forgotten your mission, your ideals, and the promises you made.
People grow up.
And now you're flown aimlessly through.
Yet even so, you are unable to escape your fate as a guardian of peace.
Okay, you were trying to kill.
You submit to a higher power and act as a weapon for them.
Just as you did as a guardian of peace.
In the end?
Shadow peace.
Did she tell you to forget everything and live on?
Or...
To pursue true peace?
I can't remember.
If you can't remember, then let me remind you.
Juha is dead.
You were there when it happened.
No!
Now you're living a carefree life, free from any memory of her death.
No, that's not true!
I see her!
She's there right now!
Every time the doctor lights the incense, I see her.
Oh, I buried the memory deep inside me.
I like trauma forgot.
Are you crying?
Oh...
...
Go...
...ZiLuan...
...down your own path?
The accident wasn't...
Literally the accident wasn't your fault.
Are you crying?
NOOOOO!
I...
...fine.
I trauma forgot for a reason!
He really is cel-
Can I just carry her out?
Just do CPR.
She just breathed too much smoke guys.
I buried that trauma deep inside me.
Why would he remind me of this?
Wait, who dragged me out though?
What the fuck?
Yeah, where is she?
Who dragged me out?
It is him!
Bye long!
Maybe I was being foolish.
Desperately clinging to a past that will never return.
Wait, then what the fuck was that little boy I was talking to this entire time?
If you insist on following the Han and allied with Tsao...
What the fuck was I talking to?
I will not hesitate to stand against you once more.
He was alive.
You must remember who the Han are to us.
Well, the point may be moot if Tsao Tsao is crushed by Yuan Shi.
Tsao in the next battle.
I will- Oh my god.
I look forward to seeing him struggle.
I am crazy.
I was talking to my inner ghost this entire time.
It's not that child?
Is that not him?
Is Bai Lang not the child?
I thought Bai Lang was the child.
I heard something's about to happen in Guan Du.
And I do not like the sound of that.
That's not him?
I was gonna say, I thought that was the- I thought Bai Lang was the child.
I knew it!
I knew I was crazy!
I knew I was- it's frantic.
I knew there shouldn't have been more than one voice in my head.
I believe now is the time for you to face the real Chu-ha.
You should figure out what it was that all of you staked your lives to accomplish.
You, Chu-ha, Bai Luan.
No, Bai Luan is the child.
How would I do that?
Don't you think you're underestimating me, Ziluan?
I think you ought to place a little more faith in me.
The key to unlocking your past is most likely the incense used by the Guardians of Peace.
The incense?
How do you know- wait, how do you know this?
I investigated your village and went through just about every relevant text I could find.
It took a great deal of time.
However, I'm afraid the truth is crueler than you might imagine, Ziluan.
I would understand if you wish to avoid learning the truth.
That, too, is a valid choice.
But, if you do decide you want to unravel your past- Look, it was the good shit, okay?
Those incenses hit good.
That said, we had best try out the incense first of all.
I will be rather embarrassed if it doesn't help you remember anything.
It made me talk to my dead ghost girlfriend.
With such an eminent family, Yuan Shao stands out as truly powerful- And then I trauma forgot everything.
The fact that- Oh my god, Destiny- Wait, I can afford this!
Oh my Dragoon's Destiny EX.
That's when you know it's good.
Wait, I can actually just afford it.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh my god, the EX means it's good.
I learned that from Pokemon.
When they're Pokemon cards.
Okay, let's see.
We still have not done the tactics.
Oh my god.
I just never stand on high ground.
I just- I don't know.
I just never go high ground for some reason.
Extra expensive!
Alright, I need to make sure.
Alright.
Go show them what you're made of.
Uh...
Let's see.
Here we go.
Oh yeah, I should- Okay, since- I should get the- Replace the- Aw, to get rid of my- Gotta get rid of my wind attack.
Sad.
What is this?
Unleash a shockwave of ice.
Jesus!
Okay, yeah, that- Oh my- Yeah, see- That seems really good.
It literally takes up my entire sly of stuff.
Ah!
Okay.
I'll go to the village.
Yeah, but if I have wind in there, I'm gonna just spam wind all the time and never save up for ice.
My dead girlfriend!
My friend!
Even when dead, she has killer eye shadow.
And mascara.
And were cut down.
And now, you know.
I am- I am- But a fragment of your memory.
Being dead doesn't mean she won't have time to make herself look pretty.
Born of your deep...
Painful regret...
Over having survived that day.
Yeah, she gotta say.
I think...
This...
Will probably be the last time you'll see me.
You...
Do not need me anymore.
Wait, no!
No, no, no, no!
Don't go!
Stay with me!
The dreams we share.
The path we chose.
That fucking meme.
Don't go!
The hopes that I passed on to you.
I made my own choices.
My own decisions.
I lived my life without regrets.
Feeling guilty for our deaths only cheapens our resolve.
So please, do not blame yourself anymore.
From this point on, do not let your desire to atone for your past shape your future.
Instead, be guided by your will to see your choices through.
Now, go forth.
You do not need to look back at us anymore.
What?
Goodbye.
Watch over me.
Was I...
Filled this hole that you left?
Of course.
I always will.
Ziluan.
Take care of Bailuan for us.
Like, I haven't ever saw the real Bailuan and I don't...
I don't, like, see...
Alright, so was that the incense talking or was I actually talking to a ghost?
Doctor, did you light up the incense?
And the doctor was like, wait, I haven't light it up yet.
Good.
It seems you were able to remember Chima.
Oh, she did!
That success is a weight off my mind.
You did well.
I officially pronounced you cured.
I'm cured?!
What did you do?!
Yes.
There is nothing more to be done.
You laid up sticks!
That's all you did!
Well, I haven't really decided just yet.
That's sad.
I've always thought of visiting the land where my father studied medicine.
Perhaps now is the time.
As for you, Ziluan...
That would be 100k.
He cured my mental illness.
Guys, he cured my schizophrenia.
I don't see my fucking dead girlfriend anymore.
Holy shit.
But I still...
I'll miss you.
I'll miss you!
Choo!
Our journey has been one of the most rewarding times in my life.
I met so many people.
All fighting to survive this chaotic era.
On second thought, maybe I could linger for a while longer yet.
After all, what better place to fulfill my duty?
Your duty?
Like how?
I don't have...
Why am I given a choice to say anything?
It's one choice!
Well, I call it a duty, but it's a humble matter compared to the exploits of someone like yourself.
It's like, here's the choices you have.
One.
Along with that knowledge, they passed down the ideal of healing the sick and aiding the wounded.
Now that I'm of a certain age, it's my duty to pass that ideal onto someone else.
Just as Chuuha passed her dreams and ideals onto you.
Which is a roundabout way of asking.
Would you let me travel with you a little while longer?
Oh my god, my doctor wants this.
Can I say...
I can't even say...
Okay, I don't understand.
What is there to understand?
I can't even say no.
Let me accompany you on your adventures.
Just as I have been.
And please...
Don't make me beg.
Beg.
Now.
I shall continue to get your service and provide what help I can.
I thought you wanted to see your father!
Like, not see your father.
I thought you wanted to do what your father wanted you to do.
I can't say no.
Oh my god.
I don't have a choice.
He must follow me.
I don't understand them.
What about the little kid?
Like, why did I see those little kids?
One, two, three.
Ultimate Musou is good.
Okay, I'll get that next time.
What did you do, Lord Cao Cao?
Their numbers...
What, Kid Toki?
You took your men?
Yuan Shao's army is growing cautious as it nears Guandu.
It appears their loss in Baima has shaken them.
But with our supplies dwindling, Yuan Shao must know that time is on his side.
And yet, then...
Any news from Shu City, Guo Jia?
Lord XunYu says that lords in the vicinity of Shu City are showing signs of revolt.
And there are rumors that Liu Bei was spotted among the leaders of the rebellion.
Liu Bei?
His majesty has taken a liking to Liu Bei.
If he comes to the rescue, then his majesty will follow him.
But Liu Bei's on the Emperor's side.
Then it is imperative that we send more troops to put the rebellion down, yes?
Do not be so nervous, Lord Shun-Yu.
Those who lack the heart of a warrior...
Okay, his... I can't say Guad, yeah, seriously.
Because his voice reminds me of...
Uh... Yamalak?
Was it Yamalak?
From Solar Opposites.
Like the little... the little kid from Solar Opposites.
That fucking brat.
If anyone ever watched that show, he literally sounds like him.
They say Liu Bei is in Shu City.
I wonder if Zhang Fei and the others are all right.
Then we have to go.
Agreed.
But only after we get permission from Lord Cao Cao.
We accepted his help.
So we must thank him properly.
And we need to take custody of Liu Bei's family.
Once we've settled our affairs here, we'll begin our journey.
Does that sound good to you?
Okay, I wanna say something really fucked up.
But like...
Ever since...
I'm gonna say it.
But I think...
Who...
Okay, who's the writer for Community again?
The guy who...
Okay, this is off topic from Dynasty Warriors.
But...
What was his name?
Um...
Fuck, the creator of Community.
So...
I think he is an incredibly great...
Dan Harmon.
I think Dan Harmon is an incredibly great writer.
Um...
Terrible work ethic though.
Terrible work ethic.
And like, might treat his...
Might treat workers pretty poorly.
But...
But he is a...
He is a great writer.
And I will say...
That when...
Justin Roiland...
Wrote shows with him...
Um...
The writing...
Degraded...
A lot.
Because it was all based off of like...
His improv.
And then it like...
It fucked with the plot.
And I think...
I think when...
When...
Dan Harmon took over...
Solar Opposites.
And...
Uh...
Like when he...
Like not...
When like...
Justin Roiland got replaced.
I think the shows...
That like...
Dan Harmon was involved in.
And also...
Solar Opposites.
Got a lot better...
Plot wise.
Because like...
And like...
Humor wise.
Cause it wasn't just like...
Random...
Hee hee...
Uh...
Pee pee poo poo...
Humor anymore.
There was more plot...
And like...
Witty writing.
But that's my like...
Hot take.
I think that was my biggest issue.
Cause that...
They...
Rely too much...
On like...
Improv...
Humor.
Like...
Improv takes.
Than...
Um...
Than actual like...
Writing.
And like...
Making shows like...
Witty and stuff.
Um...
Cause like...
Solar Opposites...
Actually got...
A lot better...
In terms of...
Writing wise.
When it...
Didn't rely on like...
The improv stuff.
Um...
And also...
I think...
Rick and Morty...
Actually...
Writing wise...
Improved a lot.
Because it was degrading.
And then it actually got a lot better.
Because Stan Harmon...
Took over...
Like...
The whole writing segment of the show.
Uh...
Um...
But that's...
My opinion.
Yeah.
I think...
I feel like...
It got...
A lot better.
Alright.
Of course.
Yeah.
Uh...
Once we sell...
Then we'll begin...
Yeah.
Do you even need to ask?
Cause I still kept watching Rick and Morty...
Even though like...
The writing got...
Like...
It...
Clearly like...
You know...
It was like...
Down a little bit.
The humor wise.
But it got a lot better.
The hundred thousand...
The hundred thousand li march of Guan Yin.
Something's about to happen in Guan Du.
And I do not...
But like...
He's not like...
A great person.
I would not...
Dan Harmon!
Like...
There's stories of like...
How he...
Treated people.
So...
But he's a very talented writer.
He's a different person when he drinks.
This town has gotten...
I wanna see if there's like...
Any...
Extra areas to go.
I wonder if that's...
I have anybody in mind.
Did anyone send me a ye olde super chat?
Well...
Alright...
Oh my god!
Greetings, Doc Doki!
I heard from the doctor that you regained...
Gained your memories!
Congratulations!
With that case up...
I was sure Master Yuan Ha would take some...
Time to rest.
But something just isn't right with him.
He seems to fall into a trance to stare into the air at the strangest time.
I went to get some medicine from him the other day.
I brought him the meal of wild vegetables he enjoys.
So much as a reward for the trouble.
But his reaction fell far short of his typical delight.
If Master Yuan Ha is depressed...
I can't help but worry about him.
What if you try to cheer him up?
I think that might help.
Please do whatever you can to help him.
Wait, who's...
Oh, wait.
He's depressed?
Why are you depressed, little boy?
Why are you...
Is it because we don't use incense anymore?
Yeah, how am I supposed to treat...
Cheer up the little...
The doctor?
Things have gotten so much better around here that you can hardly recognize the place.
What does peace even look like?
More customers always show up whenever...
Alright.
Let's see.
I need to...
Oh, yeah.
I should...
I need to still do the pie...
Pie down thing too.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Uh...
Let's just like...
Grab a different...
Thing too.
Peace bringer.
Oh, my God.
Do I bring...
I shall force...
This is called peace bringer?
Holy fuck.
Okay.
I shall bring peace with violence.
Jesus.
Why is that?
Okay.
Whatever.
The fact that this is peace bringer.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm not gonna use the ice.
Eh...
Uh...
Fuck it.
We'll do it.
For peace.
Permanent peace.
Ha ha ha ha.
Alright.
What are my objectives again?
Uh...
I almost have seven.
Defeat.
Uh...
Root from a wheel recovery.
Defeat foes with charge.
Strong attack.
Okay.
I need that.
And then...
I need...
This stupid staff thing.
Wait.
I have another one?
What was the other one?
Charge.
Continuous attacks.
Oh.
I guess people will be peaceful if they can summon someone...
If they can summon volcano attack.
For peace!
Do I have like any like optional fights here?
Oh, I do.
Jesus.
I need to be 42?
For that?
How about this one?
Okay.
Oh, that's a baby one.
Yeah.
I'll take care of that.
I'll take care of the baby fight.
Wait.
This is a baby one.
I should do the...
My weaker...
Yeah.
I should do the weaker one.
Um.
Which one was it?
Lance.
Yeah.
I don't have a strong lance.
Uh...
Oh.
Wait on my high ground!
Oh my god!
It's...
Oh wait.
I do have a strong lance now.
Oh.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh my god!
It's time!
Guys!
Why can't you...
Come on!
Guys!
Can't get too far ahead.
Stop here and see how things shake out.
Oh my arrows are...
God damn it!
I can never rely on you guys.
I am...
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad, guys.
Did I do it?
I don't know if I did it correctly.
Oh nice!
Did I have to hit me?
Hit me.
Guys!
Come on!
I need to do this stupid mission!
Just hit me!
Hit me!
Oh, I have to get hit.
Okay.
Hit me, guys!
I need to do this stupid mission!
Nice.
Oh my god, there's still yellow turban still around?
The fuck are you guys still doing here?
Okay, nice.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
I'm just gonna do this so I can...
An expeditious advance is essential to our cause.
Everybody's dead, but I needed to do that.
Wait, what is my mission?
Defeat the veteran?
Okay, nice.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, what?
Check in the advance.
Onward, everyone!
Oh, I have to defend the gates!
Oh my god, I was not reading it correctly.
Whoops.
I got you!
An opening!
It's alright!
Hit me!
Nice!
Hello turban's never surrender!
Alright, nice!
Come on, hit me again!
Come on!
Keep hitting me!
Nice!
Come on!
Alright!
Get outta here!
The enemy officer has been defeated!
Okay, now I can actually just...
Kill you guys.
Wait, Jonfei?!
This is it!
Okay!
Get out!
This is how it's time to.
Okay, I'ma...
That's fine.
Oh wait, that's not fine!
That's fine!
Alright.
Okay, how much more do I have to do this dumb... Okay, almost done.
That's right!
You will be the final hit!
Fucking finally!
Okay, I got the lance done, and then the staff time.
Alright, thank God these guys are bad, so I can do this.
Alright.
Oh wait, I can do this too!
Oh.
Wait, am I doing... Oh wait, I did this!
I did this mission before!
Don't worry.
God damn it!
Okay, never mind, worry.
Oh, I was not paying attention to my HP!
Whoops!
Oops!
I was not paying attention to my HP there!
My bad!
I was like, why is my heart beating so fast?
That's weird!
That's awkward!
Alright, nice.
Alright, we're going to the other side now.
Jonfei, I believe in you!
Let's go!
Jonfei, don't worry, you got this!
Now I'm on the other side!
Come on!
Alright, Lupe is no way.
Lupe is fine.
See, I knew it.
I told you guys, Lupe will be fine.
Wait, what?
What did I do?
How did it worsen?
Let's give it to them!
Speed!
Oh, shit!
Things don't look too good.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, that's it!
I'm angry!
Your head is thorny!
You should touch you!
That's it!
That's- this one guy, I'm gonna kill you!
You can't see it all.
I'll take this.
I can't believe this.
The enemy officer has- Thank you for coming.
Get over here!
Since the bond between is strengthened.
That's fucking right!
Now I'm extra mad!
I'm counting on you, now and beyond.
Okay.
Concentrate!
Alright, got rid of him.
How about this?
Oh, shit!
You can't avoid your fate!
That's fucking right!
Oh, you're so dead!
Boop!
Wait, you're supposed to be dead!
What the fuck?!
That's fucking right!
The enemy officer has been defeated!
You don't get to avoid your fate!
Let's get serious!
Don't make me spin!
Oh, shit!
That's right!
Now is the time for forward momentum.
Come!
Onward!
March forward!
More?
Okay, did I do it correctly?
The spinny thingy?
Okay, I did!
Okay, I couldn't tell!
I...
This...
This is such a weird fucking special move!
Our enemies fell to my incredible might!
That's fine!
The catapults can stay there!
It's fine!
Oh, shit!
I gotta let them have one thing, you know?
It's fine!
The officer has been defeated!
You sure know how to fight!
Everything will be fine!
I believe!
Our allies are doing well!
Or even is the catapults!
Guys, how do they get up there?!
It's so...
It's so far!
Why?!
Wait!
Oh, shit!
Guys, I think I should've...
Oh, wait!
Guys!
Wait!
Wait a minute!
What do you mean the castle?
Guys!
Oh, fuck!
Wait!
Are you trying to tell me?
Oh, wait!
Am I...
Wait!
What do you mean I was supposed to defend?
Oh, shit!
It's okay!
Everything will be fine!
I finished...
It's okay!
Guys, I finished my thing though!
I finished my...
My weapon!
Alright, and then...
Oh, wait!
The enemy...
Okay, now I can change it!
It's okay!
I finished...
Guys!
But!
I finished it though!
It's okay!
It's peace!
I'm here to bring!
Peace!
It's okay guys!
I brought peace though!
Things will be fine!
I just need to kill...
There we go!
Okay!
You killed one of them!
The enemy officer has been defeated!
How about this?
We gotta get rid of him!
Just believe guys!
Just keep on believing!
Things will be okay!
Time to act!
I just need to kill him!
Oh my god!
Come on!
Please!
Jesus Christ!
He's so fucking tanky!
Everybody else was a tanky!
Why are you so tanky?!
Let's get serious!
Everyone else was so fucking weak!
Jesus!
It's just me and you!
That's it!
Get out!
How did my perfect plan fail?
What do you mean, perfect plan?
What did you do?
Alright, wait, I'll get here.
Let's go!
Alright!
One more!
Don't worry!
Jump in!
I shall finish the job!
Alright!
Jesus!
Come on!
I hate the tanky ones!
The fucking, uh...
The fucking neat sponges, right here.
Time to die.
Here, get out of that little bubble.
You think a bubble is gonna save you?
All right, last guy.
Last man!
Tell them a sad story.
Don't worry, let me... get rid of these guys first.
I will not...
What?
Are you gonna challenge me?
Wait, I got an idea.
I can use the Dra... it's just one guy anyway.
Wait, no, that's not it.
Where's Dragoon Destiny EX?
For extra strong.
Wait, there's two.
Wait.
Which one is stronger?
Oh wait, that one.
Wait.
Wait, that's the...
Where's my two... Oh, there it is.
It sounds like, where's the 264?
Extra, extra, extra strong.
That's fucking right.
I paid good money for this.
Get out of here.
Oh my god, 2008.
What the fuck?
That's right.
Dragoon, go in!
This is your job!
Oh my god.
I'm glad you did one damage.
Where is he?
You know what?
I believe you guys.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
All right, just run away.
Just...
Just run away, I guess.
Goodbye.
Who's the enemy, boss?
Where is he?
Where is the officer?
I don't know.
I wonder where he was.
I...
I wonder where the enemy was.
I guess we'll never know.
We got him, boys.
Nice.
Just need...
Okay, do we have enough for this?
Oh, we do.
Fill up and can now...
You have now acquired skill and can now activate to do so.
Complete fill up the extended and...
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Why don't you can unleash...
Or you can unleash the...
When your musu go or you press...
It's also activated without full as long as the gauge has reached the...
Oh, nice.
Okay, we did it.
I learned how to get angry.
Oh, and I got two more guards to run away.
Oh, I got a cavalry charge?
Is this right?
Yeah.
Okay, there's no way you can fuck this one up.
What's this?
Oh, I like this.
Surround me.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, you guys are not fucking doing anything with that.
There's no way you can fuck up the horse.
I should save.
Let me save real fast.
There's no way you could fuck that one up.
I refuse to believe.
Are you sure about that?
Okay, I should be nice.
All right.
I should be able to level up my remaining ones that I need to do.
There's no way.
I refuse to believe you can fuck up.
Oh, my God.
No, I can't.
Oh, but I'm on high ground.
I'm sad.
Okay, let's grab.
Okay, we need to do this for...
Let's mortify our defenses, comrades.
Boom, that's fucking right.
Come on.
That's enough.
Guys, let me go.
I need to use my...
I need peace.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to use my special.
Fuckers.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to...
I'm mad.
I'm trying to use this move.
That's literally the old...
I can't use it.
There's so many people.
There's actually just too many people that I can't charge.
I literally can't charge my attack.
I can't charge my attack.
Oh, my God.
I finally completed it.
That was such a struggle.
I...
Okay.
All right.
That's it.
I'm getting...
I'm getting it out.
I'm...
I'm out.
I finished it.
That's it.
Dragoon Destiny.
Get in here.
It's over.
I'm done.
All right.
It's fucking over for you.
I'm done to play around.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I can't.
Where are the rest of the horses?
Get all these horses out of here.
Jesus Christ.
I'm fucking...
I'm losing it here.
I'm gonna lose it.
My God.
I already killed a thousand.
You are a true warrior of the three kingdoms.
Where are all the horses?
I can't tell where they are.
I'm getting angry.
I'm getting mad.
I don't know where all the horses are.
I'm mad now.
I'm just gonna use ice.
That's right.
I didn't know where all the horses were.
I got mad.
Where did it all go?
You must be good.
Let us fight.
The old brand one is the key to turning the tide.
You get in pursuit.
Immediately.
All my might.
Jesus, there's so many.
Inner fire.
Where do I have to go?
Where am I?
Jesus Christ.
All right, do something.
There's six of you.
There's still enough time.
Oh my god.
Nice.
I don't know what's going on anymore.
Things are...
I'm at 2,000.
How did I get to 2k?
I literally got to 500.
Nice.
Jesus Christ.
Guys.
Look at all these widows.
Holy fuck.
Look at all the widows I made, guys.
Okay.
I'm almost close to the ice.
Ice time!
Holy fuck.
Okay, yeah.
That move is strong.
You guys were right.
That move is actually strong as fuck.
Like, I don't even know how I accidentally traveled to the bandit leader.
Like, there's so many things going on on my screen.
I don't even know how.
Like, things just keep happening.
Oh, fuck.
Like, I just killed four different people.
I...
The enemy officer.
I just killed four different people at once.
That's crazy.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
It should be the last guy.
Goodbye!
We end this now!
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Yay!
Holy shit.
Okay, the ice move is actually so fucking strong.
This territory is ours.
Looking rough.
Whoa.
That...
That ice move, like, gave me a thousand deaths.
Like, passively.
There were just bodies around me at that point.
I'm just like, what happened?
Yeah, that move was actually insane.
Alright, I completed his stuff.
Uh...
Alright, we need more attack.
Another knot in the belt.
It's gamer time.
Nice, I got two guards to run away even more.
That's cruel.
That's cool.
Two more guards to run away from.
Alright, this way.
Gah!
Lord Zulu one has a discerning...
Wait, I should have enough for...
Story...
Uh...
Yeah, I should have enough for my second tier.
For my romance.
Lord Zulu one has a discerning...
Okay, it should be like...
Okay, I don't know where he is, though.
I need to look...
Go back.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, wait.
He doesn't want to talk to me?
I...
Go show him what you're made of.
I completed your objectives!
Why don't you want to talk to me?
Wait, where did my objective...
Oh, there is his.
Alright.
Oh, I tend to his stupid battle art chain.
That's the one thing I forgot.
God, fucking...
He gave me so many missions.
I don't keep track of it.
He gave...
He gave me too many missions!
With fully charged strong attacks using...
Didn't I do that?
Does it have to be even more fully charged?
Eh.
Oh, I guess...
I...
I guess I'll do chin poos.
I need...
From either...
Either...
With wide attacks from either gauntlet stance.
Okay, how...
Do I have the weapons for it?
I do.
Alright, it's time.
It's time to do the old man one.
I have two stages charge?
Okay, that shit was fucking rough.
I should be a left level, yeah.
Also, El, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's been a pretty bad week for me, so thanks for streaming today, Doki.
It really brings a smile to my face.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you've been enjoying the streams and cheering you up.
Alright, we have left Lord Tau Tau's to follow the bay to a county council in you.
Someone is engaged in combat with Tau Tau's forces nearby.
We cannot be certain that they are my brother's troops, but it's worth confirming.
Our primary concern at present is Lord Tau Tau's numerous checkpoints.
Though he has given us permission to pass, given the current battle, I imagine we will see some resistance.
We are forced to fight our way through...
This is the most plot we've ever had for Dynasty Warriors stream.
Like, we have... we did not have...
I'm so sad.
We...
The lack of romancing is making me upset!
As such, we will have Lube's family stay in the castle.
Only we will venture forward.
Even if I must travel a thousand lean, I will reach my sworn brother's side, as befits my vow.
Let me your strength, Natoki.
Let us show Lube our quality.
All right, nice.
My time has come.
I need to be...
Feed me!
No matter the obstacle, let us return to Lube's side.
I will die!
Feed me or I die!
Yeah, I have to...
Okay, there is...
What...
What's going on?
Stop right there!
We're in the middle of a battle.
I cannot let you pass without permission.
I am Guan Yu.
I have received Lord Tao Tao's house.
Wait, how come you get the red horse?
Wait, you died during this fight!
Wait!
That's not fair!
That's fucked up!
He gets to keep the red horse?
I have to find my brother, even if it means forcing my way.
Forgive me!
That's fucked up.
That's actually fucked up.
Is that it?
I'm doing it?
Yeah, okay.
Is that it?
I'm just gonna keep doing that.
Boom!
Ha ha ha ha!
Nice!
Get out of here!
I'm not worthy!
Let's go!
Open that door!
I'm sad!
Open the door!
I'm sad now!
I spent two, almost two hours killing Lupu and I don't even get rewarded.
I understand that it's your duty to stand in my way.
But still, I must get through to find my brother!
Get out of here!
Okay.
That's fucking right!
I hate to be right sometimes.
Get out of here!
I can't believe this.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
There's the other guy.
Time to act.
Is that it?
That's right!
That one guy!
Get fucked!
I wanted to avoid fighting them if I could.
But I suppose we must brush off these embers so we don't catch fire later.
Nice!
I don't know what's going on, but nice!
Jesus!
What the fuck?
Okay, get out of here!
All right, it's your turn!
Oh, what the fuck?
How did I get interrupted?
That's right, get punched!
God, this battle art fucking sucks.
I hate this battle art.
Oh my god!
Who let you attack so many times?!
I'm just using my face!
That's right!
Okay, nice!
All right, get punched!
Get punched!
You just dodged it?!
How do you just jump behind?
That's right, I'll never stop punching!
It's so goofy!
All right, coming back!
Oh my god, nice.
I gotta battle it.
Okay, nice.
He's gotta keep punching.
I can't believe he would just jump away from my fist like that.
That's fucked up, buddy.
That's all I have.
Oh my god, he just fights back.
Fine.
I can fight back, too.
Get out of here!
I'm bringing a fist to a knife fight.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Well, I still can.
Alright, how much more do I have?
How much more do I have?
Fifty!
Okay.
Still fifty more.
Okay, I'm actually progressing a lot faster than I thought I would.
For fifty.
I thought I had... I didn't realize I killed that many people.
Looks like we have a long way to go still.
Let's pick up the pace a bit.
Sorry.
I'm just trying to... Sorry, Guan Yun.
Just XP things, okay?
Hey, how do I...
Guan Yun, what do you... Wait, Guan Yun, where are you?
Wait, did he just... Oh, I could...
Oh, I could just ride around.
Oops.
I was like, where did he go?
I got confused, okay?
I was like, where did... Where did Guan Yun go?
Guan Yun, please!
Give me more XP!
Stop killing all of them!
I need the XP, Guan Yun!
Let's go!
You rotten deserters!
Your little journey ends here!
What do you mean?
Tauchou promised!
You'll have to get by me first!
He said I could go home!
Close the gates!
Prepare to engage these traitors!
The third gate is getting closed?
Oh my god, this stupid Brock!
Wait, how did he...
How did he do that?
Drive us off the cliffs.
How did he...
We must proceed carefully here.
How did he jump?
I forgot how he...
Oh!
Sorry!
I don't remember how he jumped!
I was so confused!
Okay, I was like, how did he do that?
How did he do that?
That's so fucking weird.
Look, I got confused, okay?
Okay, I don't need that.
I got spirit, though.
Okay, I might have been confused, but I got spirit.
Oh my god, I did it.
Okay, nice.
It's done.
It's actually done.
Alright, we did that.
Then we have... I mean, I guess we could do panic.
Oh my god.
We need to fucking successfully get a tactic in before we do any of that bullshit.
Alright, where's Dragoon's Destiny EX?
Where is it?
Alright, there we go.
Wait.
Is that the prop one... the EX we want?
Okay, I'm so confused with all of these stats.
EX plus four.
Oh wait, EX plus four.
That's better because it's plus four.
Take this.
That's right.
I'm done fucking around.
I see it.
There we go.
I have a better weapon now.
Big number.
Alright, get over here.
Alright, nice.
We can't use Musou Attack yet, Guan Yin.
I know you want to.
But we gotta save it.
We gotta save it for Tao Tao.
Whoops.
Accidentally ate a bun.
Boom.
Alright, that's three big booms.
Let's go.
We go this way.
Horse Thief?
What are you doing here?
Tao Yun?
Oh, this is awkward.
Hey, um... I'm wearing your old armor.
This is awkward.
Where?
Has he been chasing that horse Thief this entire time?
It's possible.
I would very much like to speak with Lord Liu Bei.
Lord Tao Yun.
How are you not caught him?
He doesn't even have a horse.
I, too, am searching for him.
I never... This seems more complicated than I had thought.
Lord Guan Yu.
I will join you in your search.
Perhaps together, we can find Lord Liu Bei.
Oh.
You would be a great help indeed.
Yes.
Let us go together.
Alright.
That's awkward.
That's so awkward.
Hey, like, I normally wear your old clothes, but like, hey.
You know... Look.
It's just, you know...
I found it, okay?
That's... That's really it, Talion.
I found these clothes.
It's over there.
You cannot allow them to return to Liu Bei's side.
Oh, wait.
Why is the horse thief there?
I'll have to deal with you.
Oh, what?
Wait.
Guys, I found the horse thief.
Alright, you can't fuck this up, dragoons.
There's no way.
There we go.
See?
Oh, fuck.
No!
Oh, no.
I wasted my Musou accidentally.
I finally found him!
I'll figure out a way to join him.
And then I'll never leave his side.
Oh, my God.
It's now secretly following Guan Yin.
You're amazing!
Oh, my God.
He's secretly following us now.
Alright.
When will I ever be on high ground to launch my arrows?
Will it ever happen?
I feel like by the time...
I feel like by the time we get there...
Okay, we gotta save our...
I'm gonna save the ice attack.
Until it matters.
I'm going for a quick run.
We'll see how useful I can be.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm...
I got bored.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
That's all it did?
Okay, maybe I should stop.
Wait, I can do it with Calvary Charge, too?
Oh, wait, that's good.
That's the last of them.
We did it, my lord.
No, we just gotta kill him.
Oh, lord.
Go.
Uh, no.
I just...
It's an old habit.
Well, whatever.
My name is Jonsan.
Alright.
Let's go.
Wait, I can do this.
Just for XP.
Please.
Take me under your wind.
We're going you.
We aren't out of danger yet.
Boom.
We did it.
You may come with us for now.
Open the door.
He's right there.
Open it.
I'll follow you to the farthest reaches of the kingdom for as long as I live.
Open the door.
He's right here.
I can't stop them.
He doesn't...
No!
We almost got out.
It's okay.
It's time.
But if you must insist on standing in my way, then prepare to meet my blade.
That's fucking right.
This is it.
That's right.
You pissed off the wrong person.
I don't need to duel him if I just beat Guan Yun.
Why duel him when I can beat Guan Yun, guys?
Why waste my time with that?
When I could just do this.
Get closer, please!
Get cl...
Ooh...
Good point.
You did it!
There's a second half?
Wait, what do you mean?
Wait, no.
The map ends here, guys.
It says, map end.
Hahaha.
Where's the victory?
Victory?
Wait!
Why is there so much more?
When does this map get bigger?
Hey!
Wait, did the map just got bigger, guys?
I can't...
So that unit belong to Guan Yu.
The great officer can turn the tide of battle with but a handful of men.
Let us proceed with caution.
And finish off Mubei.
Post-aste.
Okay.
Wait.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
It would seem that fortune has finally deserted us.
Where is he?
Oh, my God.
Don't worry!
Open the door!
We shall fight and survive until Guan Yu comes!
Brothers!
I have returned!
Me!
Your fourth brother is here!
Yes, me!
Me!
My brother!
You have much to discuss!
But first, let us escape this peril!
And the enemy officer has been defeated!
We have much to discuss!
But first, let us escape this peril!
The fourth brother is here, guys!
Me!
We must continue to fight hard!
Lord Liu Bei!
It's good to see you after so long!
My spear is at your service!
More infested!
The enemy officer has been defeated!
There's so much plot and if I'm killing so many people!
Okay, nice!
For the brother of my lord, I shall spare no effort!
Oh my god!
Like 20 different plot lines was here!
And he's still going!
Let's just say a man who insisted on offering his services!
Literally 20 different plot lines were just shown today!
Alright, nice!
Oh my god, Lupe!
You're almost dead!
Why did you not eat your bread?!
Everyone!
Please!
Eat your bread!
Stay strong!
Alright, I think I did like a lot though!
Alright, I completed that!
I still have yet to do a traumatic success yet!
We're getting there, guys!
We're...
We're slowly getting there!
Alright, I mean I could do...
I'll just get rid of Panton's stupid fucking...
What is the wheel recovery?
Is it this?
Like, how do I do the wheel recovery?
I don't understand!
This area belongs to us now!
Okay, where are we supposed to go, guys?
We're going this way?
I don't know!
I don't know where we're supposed to go!
Oh, hit Y when they're...
Oh, okay!
Alright, I got this!
I got to quit charging into things!
Take this!
No!
Okay...
Oh, shit!
There we go!
Nice!
I don't know what I'm doing, but nice!
Jesus Christ!
He's so tanky!
I don't know if like...
If it's because, um...
Of how weak my weapons are...
Or if he's just naturally this fucking tanky!
I can never tell anymore!
Okay, nice!
That's fine!
I'm gonna save my...
I'm gonna save my rage meter!
Guys, I don't think you matter anyway!
Nice!
He's just pretty tanky!
Oh, thank god!
Okay, I couldn't tell!
Oh my god!
Get outta here!
Doesn't matter if I break your neck anyway!
The enemy officer enemy's arrival has revitalized the foe!
We are in danger!
Doesn't matter how tanky you are if I can still break your neck!
We shall stop them there!
Alright!
Nice!
Boom!
I can't believe this!
The enemy officer has been defeated!
Alright, fast track!
You call that an officer?
Okay!
One day I'll figure out how to do a dramatic success tactic!
One day!
But today is not that day!
Today is sadly not that day, guys!
Great!
But one day I'll figure it out!
Okay, nice!
Jesus!
Oh no!
There's so many things going on!
That's...
Yeah, exactly!
That's future Doki's problem!
Nice!
Oh my god!
I killed a lot of people that was there!
Oh wait!
Is he the boss?
Oh he's the boss!
Okay, how much more?
Complete it!
Wait, where's Pantong?
Did I not do it?
Oh my god!
Fuck this!
I give up!
I give up already!
Fuck it!
I'm using ice!
I hope...
I do not!
I...
Have chosen my path!
Gotcha!
I was at...
Guys!
The thing is, I was at 25!
Nice!
Do I hit him?
Oh, I do!
Alright, who's gonna...
Am I gonna finish this fight before the plot is done?
Yes!
I actually...
I killed him before they were finished talking!
Alright, oops!
Sorry guys!
Finished it too early!
Unlimited potential.
One slight underestimation on our part could lead to our destruction.
Don't bother us...
No!
But the training is how I romance the Generals!
I'm too strong for the plot!
You have your family safely accompanying us too!
Ah!
My thanks!
You have protected them well!
Lube!
Were you even thinking about your child and your...
Your wife?
More than anything!
I am thankful for that!
Now...
Looking rough!
Tell me a tale or two...
They won't let me pay him!
That's the worst part!
I'm trying!
I've been trying to pay him this entire time!
He won't let me!
All right...
Let's see...
Greater...
Boost...
Defense...
Alright...
I definitely need more health recovery...
Fuck that!
He won't let me!
I wanna get closer!
But he won't let me!
Thou whore!
There must be someone else.
It is good to have you two back with us.
We shall meet again.
I made it a mantra until we were reunited.
And now, I will make my oath to you once more.
From this day onward, I will dedicate my life to clearing the path for Rise of Liu Bei.
To a brighter future.
Thank you both.
So you didn't decide to abandon me.
That's a relief.
And not just for you, brother.
I'd had just about enough of him asking, are they back yet?
Every time he saw me.
If you'd left me alone with him much longer, I might have given him a good smack on the head.
Oh, just like his son.
That's where he got it from.
Okay, it took this guy like 20 years to catch them.
I don't even have a place to call home.
But what brings you all this way?
I have come to lend you my aid, Lord Liu Bei.
I wish to serve under you.
Me?
I don't even have a place to call home.
Why would you wish to serve a vagrant?
Because of who you are.
Is that not reason enough?
Well, I...
Okay, it took this guy like 20 years to catch the horse thief.
My lord!
Don't forget about me!
He's like, I don't know him.
My lord.
Brother, allow me to introduce.
Ron Yu's top underling, Jill Sung, at your service.
I admire him so much that I followed him and begged him until he took me under his weight.
I see.
That sounds like quite the story.
My lord!
Well, we should have let all this excitement go to waste.
Brothers, fetch the wine.
Tonight, we welcome our friends with a feast.
I just realized...
If I play the other chapters...
I have to kill Lu Bu again.
Guys, I don't know anymore.
I...
Guys, am I really strong enough to kill Lu Bu a second and third time?
It'll be easier.
I, for some reason, I don't trust you guys.
How distant they are.
Those stars in the sky.
Wow.
It's so romantic, guys.
Compared to them, the distance between men seems trivial.
It is your open-heartedness that makes you feel so.
Don't deny your destiny!
I don't know, dad surely didn't.
That's why he's in fucking doggy jail right now.
What's up?
I...
Thank you.
All of you.
Though I cannot offer you compensation at this time.
I shall swear to you again.
Together, we shall journey throughout this vast land.
We shall!
Yay!
Oh, we finished chapter four!
Wait, how many chapters was there again?
Was it two more?
We weren't joking about no hidden infrared hair.
You should totally unlock it.
It's your destiny warrior piece.
The shame Lu Bu.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, it's five chapters?
Wait, there's five chapters left?
Or...
This is the last chapter?
We're at the last- Oh, how long is the last chapter?
From a decisive battle with Yuan Shao.
Becoming the most powerful individual in the land.
He actively strove to establish hegemony over Hu Bei.
And in turn, the entire land.
The Sun clan fell into turmoil.
After being tragically deprived of their war once again.
Oh, Sun Se is dead.
However, with their combination of capable youth and dependable seniority...
Don't worry, he still has his roommate.
Oh, my God!
The roommate's...
His...
The roommate's ex died!
Their future now lay in the hands of their young leader.
Joe Yu was like...
My new roommate.
And could not realistically attempt to gain supremacy.
But...
He focused on gaining something worthwhile out of his indecision.
The turbulent sea of the era turned into a powerful whirlpool.
And before long...
Oh, my God!
My Oshi!
My Oshi is right there!
Chapter 5.
With Chuga Liang's assistance...
Chuga Liang?
Liu Bei decides on a plan to gain power.
Oh, my God!
My Oshi!
There he is!
Yes!
Wow, Oshi!
Oh, my God!
Both sides struggled to gain an advantage at Guandu.
But in the end...
Yuan Xiao's forces were crushed after Tao Tao raided their storehouse.
With no hope of recovery...
Lord Yuan Xiao eventually succumbed to illness.
I see.
I owed Lord Yuan Xiao a great debt of gratitude for helping me when I most needed it.
Oh, Yuen Shao's dead.
I never got a chance to complete his training.
Or him to repay him.
Oh, he's wearing green now.
That's funny.
Huh?
You don't know?
I'm changing so fast that I'm having trouble keeping up.
Hey, come on.
Don't give up now.
Wait, Zhou Zhan, Zhao Yun, you two have any ideas that can help?
Okay, they're not strateg... We don't have a single strategist here.
We're all like, unga bunga.
All right, Lupe, it's time to get to Kotlin.
We actually have zero strategist here.
I'm afraid I'm no more helpful than he is.
We're all in muscle heads.
Unga bunga is the strategy.
Bro, I barely talk.
Uh...
You can't even look me in the eye.
If you don't have any ideas, just say so.
You know, I think this conversation may have shown me what is holding us back.
Oh, you think?
Brother, what we need is a guide.
A man of wisdom.
We had none of that this entire time.
It took four chapters to realize this.
We actually...
Chaochao has like ten of them, and we have zero.
That's where we can find someone with the skills we need.
Do you think heading that way would be a good idea?
That's actually crazy.
Chaochao's literally surrounded by strategists.
Are you serious?
How can we go anywhere right now when we've got the castle here in Runan?
You're right.
I'm sorry, forget I mentioned it.
Perhaps some ideas are best left unsaid.
Alright.
Ooh!
I need to tell you something.
I'm looking forward to seeing you around, but let me tell you why I'm writing.
There's something I'm raring to show off to you.
I'm wearing it right now.
My new outfit designed especially to match with Lord Guan Yun.
Ever since I met him during my days fighting for the yellow turbanes.
I dreamed of that day.
That's such a great...
Why is he telling me this?
Like...
So I got this made to look just like him.
But a little bit of my own personal flair, of course.
Now, I know all the thought I put in this may come off as a tad disturbing.
I get it.
I really do.
That's why you're the only person I can practice it.
Because you know what it's like.
I mean, I'll take it all in with my word and just smile instead of teasing me about it, right?
Oh, the next time we meet, you can have all the time you want to admire it.
He's like, I know who you are.
You seem to have the ability to land unharmed when dropping from high places.
I wager for you would be fine falling from just about anything you climb.
Your sense of...
Okay.
This doesn't matter.
I was glad to see that you're in good health.
And I'm grateful to once again have the honor of meeting you in the service of Lord Lupe.
It has been too long.
So I thought we might have a nice talk to catch up on things.
If you would like, I can come to where you are.
This is so much I want to tell you.
Yay!
Finally!
The real good part about this game.
Oh my god.
Finally!
The real content, guys.
The good stuff.
Alright.
Oh wait, but Lupe wants to talk too.
But Zhao Yun has a bond.
Alright, Zhao Yun.
What do you want to talk about?
The real content.
Fading to black.
I feel embarrassed to bring this up now.
But there's something I've wanted to ask you to return.
What?
My heart.
You mean.
Peace.
What peace of your heart.
The feelings I expressed to you in the hope that you would be drawn to Lord Lupe.
I now realize I was being melodramatic.
I would appreciate it if you would forget about what happened.
That's not right again.
Ever since then.
Even separated from you.
I could feel that my heart was like you.
However.
You no longer need it.
Since you've entered Lord Luube's service, my wish has been fulfilled.
We have become true comrades now.
Oh my god.
His heart was missing me.
That's why I'm wearing his armory, guys.
Even on my travels, news of his troubles reached me.
Guys, this is exactly why I'm wearing his army!
Okay,
why are we still talking about Lube?
It's you and me!
Sorry!
Us and him!
Let me thank you once again.
You honored my wishes faithfully.
At last, I'm ready to join you.
Yes, us!
You and I!
Us and him!
Together, we can do this!
Oh, we're making progress in our relationship, guys!
We're moving in together!
Why is it that Lord Lube feels more inspiring to me?
Me and you and your Lord Lube!
Okay, we can share.
Here alongside him stand Lord Guan Yu, Lord Zongfei, and you.
Yes, this is what I've been seeking.
I'm sure of it.
I hope one day, I can put this feeling into words.
If that day comes, you will be the first to hear about him.
I'll be the first one to hear about his feelings too!
Holy shit, what the fuck?
No, I didn't...
He literally...
He literally was like, I'm here for my heart.
What the fuck?
Holy shit, I was not ready for that.
I said that as a joke, guys.
I said that as a joke.
They know they're dark.
Wowza!
That's crazy.
It's you.
That's actually crazy.
That's the most case ever.
I threw the fact that he...
Okay, I think...
I think that was a good time to stop it.
Next stream will be the stream where we finally finish...
the Shu...
Dynasty Warriors arc.
And then we can close this chapter.
That is a good way to end that from today's stream.
Next stream will be the final part.
I'm gonna ask for...
I'm gonna put a poll up on what time for the final stream.
But since it is the final stream, maybe I'll put it at my other time slot, the 5pm PSC.
I know there's some people that have been watching...
Like, some Eeyongans have been watching at 1230.
So I will do a...
I'm gonna put a poll up to figure out the time slot for the final part.
Because, like, I'm just thinking of, like, the Asia Dragoons.
We wanna watch the final part.
Um...
But yes, um...
I'll put a poll up later tonight on the time slot.
So, um...
The next part will be the final part for Dynasty Warriors.
Uh...
Hey guys!
That was fun.
That was really fun.
I had a great time.
NotSoDeadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It has strategized knight formations with most generals.
And...
Um...
We!
Not just me.
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Anyway, that was a good wave.
You know how we were like...
I was like, man!
Where's the actual content, guys?
Like, I'm...
We were like...
Aw, man!
I feel like...
We're missing out on the real content.
And then it didn't...
It didn't disappoint.
It didn't disappoint at the end.
The end was where...
It was...
Where they...
The build up to the end.
For the actual good content.
That's what we're...
That's...
That's what I'm talking about.
That's what we've been waiting for.
Hey guys!
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you step for me...
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!